this is Jocko podcast number 201 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing good
evening echo good evening I had left my
daughter Maggie with my parents while I
and my business partner drove a few
minutes away to look at a vacant store
right in the heart of town as soon as I
saw it I knew it would be perfect as the
landlord was putting the lease in my
hand for me to sign my cell phone rang
and I saw was my mom thinking she was
just checking to see when I would be
back I ignored the call when my phone
immediately rang again I knew something
was up
my initial fear was that something
happened to my 10 month old daughter my
mind went to the worst place and at the
time I didn't think anything could be
worse than that when I answered the
phone all I heard on the other end were
muffled screams it was clearly a noise
made by someone who was so broken up and
in such a state of shock that he or she
couldn't even cry properly I didn't know
how to prepare myself for whatever news
I was about to receive and started
shaking uncontrollably tell me what
happened I cried I was terrified that
something horrible had happened to
Maggie had she tripped and split open
her head choked on something my mind was
running wild with possibilities not
knowing was almost worse than knowing at
this point have you called an ambulance
I yelled yes answered the voice on the
other phone before the line suddenly
went dead I knew that I was too upset to
drive I asked my business partner to
take me home a 5-minute drive I had
traveled countless times before but this
time those five minutes felt like an
eternity and while the car was crawling
through the streets my mind was racing
in a thousand miles a minute my husband
was at work about an hour away while I
wanted the comfort that his voice would
bring
I decided not to call him until I got
home to the house that could figure out
what was going on I didn't want to upset
him if I didn't have to as we pulled
onto my parent's street my heart started
racing as fast as my mind I didn't see
an ambulance anywhere in sight for a
moment that gave me a sense of relief
maybe things weren't as serious as I had
led myself to believe my dad was
standing in the driveway next to a
friend lieutenant colonel
Corky Gardner he and my father had
served together in the Marine Corps and
he was a dear friend of the family he
and his wife lived about 45 minutes away
so it struck me as odd to see him
standing there especially since my
parents had not mentioned he would be
coming over I jumped out of the car
while it was still moving where's the
ambulance I screamed my dad stared back
at me with a blank look then in a very
measured tone he said Travis was killed
I heard those words loud and clear but
they didn't make any sense to me it took
me a few seconds to process what I was
being told since the moment I hung up
the phone I'd known something was wrong
but this was far worse than anything I
could have imagined I thought my
daughter was an imminent danger and here
I was being told that my brother was
dead he was 26 years old
in that right there is an excerpt from a
book called the knock at the door three
gold star families bonded by grief and
purpose and this book is written by Ryan
Mannion who wrote that opening section
who is the sister of US Marine First
Lieutenant Travis Minh and who was
killed in Iraq there's also written by
Amy Looney hefferman the surviving
spouse of lieutenant
Brendan Looney a seal officer killed in
Afghanistan and the other author the
final author is Heather Kelly the
surviving spouse of first lieutenant
Robert Kelly a Marine Corps officer also
killed in Afghanistan and you may
recognize these names because I've
talked about all these names on this
podcast I I read a speech on podcast
number 162 about to brave Marines
Jonathan Yale and Jordan herder who held
the line at an outpost while being
attacked by a vehicle borne bomb and
these two brave marine stood their
ground and stopped the vehicle before it
could enter their outpost and kill many
more of their fellow Marines but the
bomb did detonate and it killed both of
them
and that speech was made by a Marine
Corps general general Kelly then I
mentioned when I read that speech that
general Kelly's son was killed in action
and that was that was first lieutenant
Robert Kelly and then you may have heard
me talk about Brendan Looney let's see
all that I put through training who was
loved by his brothers and the teams who
was a few days from coming home after a
tough deployment
in Afghanistan who volunteered to go on
a turnover operation and was killed in a
helicopter crash in Afghanistan on
September 21st 2010 and when I talked
about him I I spoke a lot about his best
friend Travis Manion and I talked about
Travis Manion as well when I had Brian
Stann on the podcast well Travis Manion
was killed in action on April 29th 2007
and I went into detail around the
relationship between Travis and Brendan
who are buried next to each other at
Arlington National Cemetery when I had
Travis's dad on the podcast number 72
and we discussed his book which is
called brothers forever in this book
that I'm reading from today the knock at
the door this gives a different
perspective a perspective of pain and of
anguish but also of surviving in
overcoming and of moving forward through
the pain into a place of pride and a
place of purpose and it is an honor to
have one of the authors of this book
with us here today
Ryan Mannion sister of Travis Manion to
share some of what she has learned so
Ryan thank you for coming out here and
thank you for coming on the podcast yeah
I'm really happy to be here and happy to
talk a little bit more about the book
this is a tough way to start off a book
yeah with I mean know with what's got to
be the worst day of your life I'm
assuming or at least right up there 100%
the worst day of my life and you know
it's interesting to hear you reading it
you you become a little desensitized
when you're putting things on paper and
when you talk
about it a lot but to hear you reading
it it definitely brought emotion it's
probably in the way that you read too
but it you know it it kind of brings you
back to to that place well whenever I
read something like this not only am I
thinking about what you went through
what your family what went through but
I'm also thinking about how many times
this happened to my friends my friends
families in the pain and anguish that
this that this causes and yeah it's just
you know that you you titled the book
that knock at the door and for for
anyone that doesn't understand this then
the the military has a very well-defined
protocol that they take when a service
member is killed overseas and it's a
personal notification which is which is
actually a great thing compared to what
they used to do and I don't know if
you've ever seen the what are those
little messages that they used to send a
telegram yeah like a telegram message
that's right it was a telegram they
would send a telegram that said you know
dear mr. and mrs. Smith we're sorry to
inform you that your son Barry Smith was
killed in action around this day in
around this area so at some point
someone smart realized that that was a
horrible way to notify families so they
have a very strict protocol and what the
protocol consists of is uniformed
personnel from the service branch that
the service member was in going to the
home and and knocking on the door in
full dress uniform and it's these days
what's become challenging about it is
it's a race against social media and
it's a race against the news so when you
have when you're overseas and one of
your one of your troops are killed
there's like immediate radio silence
you're not allowed to tell anyone
because it's all to prevent the family
from finding out that this has happened
on the news and let's face it even with
this
protocol which is designed to try and
support the family as much as possible I
mean it's it's still just an absolute
it's just an absolute nightmare and it's
the the worst fear of of any family that
has a service member on active duty
deployed this the worst the worst
nightmare for for all of us I think you
did a great job of capturing how that
how that impacts now before we go
further down this story I want to give a
little bit of background between between
you and Travis and I think it's it
starts to tell the story of your
relationship with him I'm going to the
book here Travis and I had been born
only 15 months apart so to say we were
close would be an understatement
the fact that ours was a military family
also brought us closer than most
siblings like many military families we
had to adjust new situations very
quickly until I was 12 when my dad left
active duty before that we had moved
almost every two years we knew that no
matter where we move next no matter what
school we ended up in or which sports
teams we'd be on be the new kids on we
always had each other to depend on
Travis had been my built-in best friend
at every stage of my life what about the
what about the sister brother dynamic
did you were you you were older so you
kind of like the I mean I was dominate
her I was the older sibling yes Thursday
there was no doubt about that and it was
funny I was having a conversation with
someone last night and they were asking
me about my relationship with Travis and
and I said you know Travis really did
look up to me and sometimes that didn't
fare him well because I was a bit of the
wild child and you know I wasn't always
listening to my parents and so I could
kind of skew him in the wrong direction
and you know looking back on things I
look at who my brother was and and he
was very driven even at a young age
there was something DIF
about him and you know I I talk about a
little bit in the book like I felt like
at times like what happened to that
piece of DNA for me because I didn't
have that drive I didn't have that
commitment to two goals or anything of
that sort but you know along with that
came this idea that in the in the way
that he was I admired him so much
it wasn't a jealousy I wasn't like oh
you know there's great Travis or you
know I was so proud of him and I was so
proud to have him as my brother so
that's pretty unique yeah I mean my I
remember in high school my girlfriends
and I we follow him around the
Philadelphia area to his wrestling
matches and we were like his main
cheering squad in the front row and I'm
like that's my brother the all-american
wrestler you know I was so proud of him
and it was it was really cool to grow up
with someone that even he was younger
than me but that I could look up to so
much you know and I think at the end of
the day he helped me from not going too
far off the rails you know it's weird
and you got three children I have three
children so I have four children and
it's weird how and I always try to
explain to people that they're gonna be
different
oh yeah you know they're gonna be
different and you just kind of have to
brace yourself as a parent which it
sounds like your parents had to brace
themselves for you oh my dad braced
himself for many many years many many
years and you know growing up I mean I I
was an athlete and they're what sports
did you play I played lacrosse through
you know I played every sport growing up
soccer basketball everything but I
played lacrosse through high school and
college and my dad always said you know
between you and Travis like you were the
born athlete like you had athletic
ability it came naturally to you like
Travis had to work hard everything he
did Travis played on I remember we moved
to Pennsylvania he played on a CYO
football team and he was a short little
chubby kid and his nickname was porkchop
and you know and and tries had to work
to become
who we became I glided right through
never worked at anything still got some
money to go to school for college and
play lacrosse and I look back down I'm
like God if I don't even applied myself
a little bit like and really tried to
work at something no it's weird that's a
that's a trait right like this work
ethic thing yeah it's a trait that some
people have and some people don't I
don't know
but what's the I heard a quote I had a
quote from one of my Brazilian friends
and he said there's a there's a saying
in in Brazil that there's a reason that
God doesn't give wings to a snake
because if he did we'd all be screwed
because the snakes could just fly around
and kill you so that's like what happens
right you can have that awesome work
ethic but you maybe don't get the full
athletic capability that is optimal or
you can be this really gifted athlete
but you know you like to party that
pretty much describes it yeah
and it's cool that you it's cool that
you didn't have this jealousy thing
going on right well I guess you were an
accomplished athlete as well so I guess
I really wouldn't be there yeah it was
that but more than that it was also like
hey my parents were so focused on Travis
that I could kind of slide by with a lot
of things you know we're we're taking
Travis to Lehigh for the the Nationals
for wrestling I'm like sweet I'm gonna
have a rager at the house this weekend
so would you legitimately do that
I legitimately did when your parents
were gone you would have ragers yes
several times and you and and did you
ever get caught so I'll tell you story
it was my brother senior year he was
going to wrestle at the National perhaps
it's it's huge I mean it's the hugest
tournament he's gonna wrestle in and he
goes up to he goes up and we my best
friend and I my mom took us out to
breakfast and she's like I'm taking out
to breakfast before they left they were
heading to Lehigh for the weekend and my
girlfriend Chris and I are sitting there
and my mom says doesn't say to me she
says
Crysta look me in the eye you are not
having a party at my house this weekend
and Krista said I promised mrs. Manion
we're not gonna have a party she said to
this this day it's like she's like I
lied to your mom's face yesterday I mean
we had we had the kegs being delivered
like you know within the hour after they
were gone and the party got a little out
of control we were you know we had all
these upperclassmen show up it was and
I'm like oh my gosh you got it got ahead
of us and so finally we get everybody
out the house is trashed and so like my
core group of friends were cleaning up
the house we're trying to get everything
taken care of and I tell my mom buddy
there's there must be 12 bags of trash
and I said take this trash you're on
trash to to get it out of here getting
in a dumpster so he leaves with the
trash and I'm feeling pretty proud I'm
like I think I think we can cover this
up you know so my parents come home the
next day and you know my mom walks in
and she's kind of like looking around
like like do you have people over here
no just Gator and I'm looking at
everything and we kind of I'm like we
got away with this it's about two hours
later
knock on the door my mom goes in the
answers the door and there's a lady
standing there with all 12 bags of trash
at the front door and she's like these
were thrown into the field behind my
house she went through the trash found
like because we had taken out the trash
with like mail in it found our dress and
and I just remembered looking at Travis
and he just shook his head I've when I
go away and you know I got teenage kids
now and even well couple them in college
now but I used to go away for whatever
with my wife or whatever and leave the
kids at home and I'm like are you guys
gonna have a rager or what I kind of
encouraged they were like no they're
like dad no none of our friends will
come to our house they like don't want
to come here because of you oh well okay
I guess that's a positive thing so
that's awesome you guys had had it's
awesome that you didn't have that
rivalry which can which can happen yeah
in in you know sibling relationships my
kids don't really have
now that I think about it what school
what about like competition like even on
a more friendly level like did you ever
feel like you're competing with him
ping-pong death matches or anything like
that I mean listen you know in life oh
yeah I mean growing up I mean as when we
were young like I used to tease them
endlessly I mean my aunt tells the story
of her wedding you know and and she said
all you did was make Travis cry by
teasing him the entire day we were like
10 and 11 years old so we fought like
siblings but I think by the time we hit
high school there really wasn't
competition like hey would I would we
get out back and play basketball and you
know yeah that's that sort of stuff like
friendly cup but like there was nothing
competitive in terms of how our
relationship worked awesome all right
you dive into this a little bit more I'm
gonna go to the book here on a wooden
wooden beam in our basement by the bench
pressing on which he would punish
himself nightly Travis wrote his goals
in permanent black marker here they are
all-american wrestler first-team all
Catholic and lacrosse maintained 3.9 GPA
my aspirations were far more modest
rarely recorded and let's be honest not
terribly and admirable while Travis's
key performance indicators consisted of
grade point averages and athletic
milestones mine were quantified by
number of parties attended or classes
skipped without getting caught Travis
had a work ethic uncommon amongst most
16 year olds and as his older sister I
found it fascinating and a little
unnerving I marveled at Travis's ability
to set a goal one year out even two
years out and then work tires tirelessly
to meet it occasionally I questioned
what genetic material was absent from my
DNA that caused this quality to skip me
but I never lost sleep about it and
though I admired his self-discipline and
focus I'm pretty sure Travis envied my
vibrant social life and light-hearted
attitude towards responsibility so you
guys kind of balanced each other out
totally did you when you were looking at
him
with his goals and everything like that
and you're saying well that skipped me
did you ever say well it didn't skip me
I can make a goal and I can go for it
did you ever did you did that ever cross
your mind or is that just not part of
your yeah I mean I have to be honest I
just didn't really care you know I I was
I was happy to take the backseat to his
stardom man you played lacrosse in
college I did I mean that's no joke yeah
I yeah I mean I broke some school
records at my play in college lacrosse
and you know what and so I don't want to
take away anything from that but it was
like I went to a d3 school I played
lacrosse I was the leading scorer on the
team and and it was a lot of fun and you
know and Travis would come to my games I
remember Travis came to one of my games
and and him and my uncle Chris were like
heckling the goalie
because the goalie had like had a cheap
shot at me I played attack I was right
up front and and so they're like
standing behind heckling the goalie and
after the game you know we win the game
and we're standing there and the coach
says the coach is like doesn't directly
say anything to me but she goes I'm just
gonna say this right now if I see
anybody's family messing with you know
messing with another team again that
so-called player will not be playing on
my team anymore and so I like leaving
I'm like thanks a lot guys you know you
come to one game and you know I'm about
to get kicked off the team for where
you're doing what the hell were they
doing I mean you got to make a pretty
significant impact on the game yeah I
mean there was it was a it was a cheap
shot by her and what you know I shot she
came out and whacked me so hard and in
an intentional way you know and and that
was my brother like he was if someone
messed with me yeah like don't mess with
me yeah I mean if someone messes with
you he's gonna heckle them yeah fine man
yeah if you're a girl you're gonna get
heckled if you're a guy oh yeah yeah so
you tell a good story in here it's like
a Saturday night and there's a party
going on and I have this ideal situation
because you've got your brother
kind of a straight and narrow kind of
guys so that means you have a designated
driver you invite him to go to this
party
the party you know it goes gets kind of
wild and then the cops show up and so
here we're going to the book teenagers
scattered Travis Krista who's were the
people you're with and I quickly found
one another and joined the mad rush
toward the back of the house we barreled
through the kitchen door hopped the
fence that surrounded the property and
sprinted for the woods behind the house
those woods were our ticket to freedom
they also represented a blessed escape
from the terrifying wrath of my parents
who almost certainly would have disowned
me for what would have been my third
underage drinking citation in my high
school career so you had some milestones
you were making you so you're running in
through the woods there's a footbridge
and somehow you fall off the footbridge
which is actually the word you using you
you say I got thrown off the footbridge
what is that even well because there's a
hundred kids running over a bridge
that's this wide you're all trying to
hit that same cornfield so we're stopped
because you get to the cornfield and
then you're good yeah cuz they cannot
find unicorns they're not running the
cops are not chasing us into a cornfield
you know cornfields are crazy yeah like
you can get lost in cornfields I have
many times yeah all right so you end up
you you end up getting thrown from this
footbridge and you could going back the
book I became aware of a pain coursing
through my leg I looked down and saw
that my shin was covered in blood my
khaki pants were red so now Travis is
like hey we got to get you some help and
you guys discussed that a little bit
finally you are gonna walk back to the
car and finally the car wasn't within
sight but just as we rounded a giant
pine tree a blinding light shone in her
eyes busted hey kids get over here a
square-jawed officer examined us with
his flashlight he wanted names ages and
a full account of our whereabouts that
evening somewhere in the interrogation
session a light bulb seemed to go off in
his head his eyes softened and his lips
turned up into a smile he wait you're
Travis Manion yes sir hell
the wrestling season you've had kid
thank you sir and so then he you know
Travis kind of plays this thing up to
get you guys to get you guys out of out
of trouble yeah so this is the kind of
this is the kind of thing that you two
had going on yeah it was did uh did your
since you guys were close in age did
your friends all hang out together oh
yeah totally
I mean my friends were his friends he'd
go out with any of your friends he's
hung out with some of my friend did you
go out with any of his friends a little
bit yeah no serious relationship my kids
are like my mom my oldest three kids are
about 18 to 24 months apart that's 18
for the first two and so there's always
but for the oldest to our girls and then
there's the boy
yeah but the weird thing is the boys
like six three and he's always been
taller than them since so I don't know
it's but there's there's like a little
in there's like a little line with my
kids the friends all hang around but
there's never been like a relationship
anywhere yeah no I mean I'll tell you
like in and I think it was my was my
senior year my senior year you know we
had I had one friend who didn't get
asked to prom and you know was a sad
thing you know and she's like
heartbroken about it and I'm like Travis
you're taking her to progress and he's
like oh no this girl I'm like you're
taking her problems like fine you know
like he always just kind of like stepped
in I mean certainly a lot of my friends
were enamored by Travis yeah I'll put it
that way
Travis was the stud yeah all right so
you guys have this awesome relationship
and I'm gonna go back now to the day you
find out
so here we go I couldn't believe it I
didn't want to believe it I collapsed in
a heap right there on the driveway I
remember thinking that the asphalt felt
unnaturally warm for a mid-april
afternoon that had been mild it's not
fair it's not fair I screamed over and
over into the sky I wanted to make sure
that everyone even God Himself knew that
he had made a terrible mistake as I
screamed my parents neighbors spilled
out of their houses to find out what was
happening my dad didn't rush to my side
to comfort me he let me get those
tortured screams out of my system before
I I went about the hard work of trying
to understand what had happened and pick
up the pieces as had always been the
case with my dad he knew exactly what I
needed before I did I have no idea how
long I lay on the ground screaming I
just know that it was long enough to get
the rage out of my system at some point
one of the neighbors helped me up and
walk me down the driveway toward my
house as I walked I turned around and
saw an unfamiliar car parked out in
front of the house in my shock I hadn't
even noticed it earlier inside sat a
young man about my age in full military
dress blues his forehead was resting on
the top of the steering wheel pressed
between two folded arms that cradled his
head his eyes were closed and he looked
dejected or perhaps unconscious I later
learned this poor marine 26 years old
had been charged with the unfortunate
task of sharing the news with the people
closest to Travis that he had been
killed in Iraq captain Eric Cahill as I
learned later learned his name was had
been assigned to carry out the job since
he was local and had graduated from the
Naval Academy the year before my brother
Lieutenant Colonel Gardner had also been
called since the military knew that he
was a family friend
close by together while I had been out
scouting sites for my boutique they had
approached my parents door and knocked
my mother opened the door took one look
at Corky in the young Marine uniform and
slammed the door in their faces
she simply couldn't face what was on the
other side like I said that's what every
every military family knows there's only
one reason that that person's come in
your house in their dress uniforms yeah
and and since since your dad was in the
Marine Corps for whatever twenty
something years and she obviously was
knew this as good as well as anyone so
she wasn't sure she could face what was
on the other side I wasn't sure I could
either when I reached the front door
with the help of my neighbor I stopped I
had walked through that door thousands
of times before but this time I wanted
to turn the other direction and run away
I knew deep down in my soul that once I
pass through that door this time the
life that I had known was over and there
was no going back that permanence
I was at the SEAL Teams I was in the
Training Command and a guy got the
wounded really bad overseas and somebody
called me and said hey this guy he got
wounded really bad and I think the guys
that caught the guy there's two guys on
the other end and I think they were
looking for like a little bit of
sympathy mm-hmm right like hey one of
the guys got wounded really bad and I
remember saying because I had heard the
initial report that a guy was wounded
really bad really bad and then these
guys this this call came probably 36
hours later and I said like hey is he
stable and they said yeah he's stable
and I said well then we're good and for
them I mean for them they were still
thinking like hey this guy's gonna lose
limbs like this guy's gonna be in really
bad shape but for me like cuz you know I
only come back from Iraq a little while
before and lost guys there yeah and so
for me the difference between hey this
guy's as messed up as this guy's gonna
be as horrible the situation is and the
wounds that he suffered are horrible but
he's gonna be here and this permanence
of what you you know that's what that's
what I was thinking about when I was
reading about you saying when you walk
through that door the line between life
and death is like no it's like you can't
even you can't even identify it it's so
so slender mm-hmm and it falls on one
side of the other yeah you know I've I
you know you go through that initial
phase of shock but I remember thinking
like why couldn't he just been like
why couldn't we be flying to Germany
right now you know and I've even had
dreams about like Travis being there but
but he's like super wounded
you know he's missing both his legs but
I'm like who cares it's Travis
you know I of course you take them in
any form if they're alive you know and
it's just that idea and I think for me
you know when my mom opened the door
it's I don't I don't write about in the
book but like it was a super volatile
time when he was there and my mom had
gotten an email a week before from the
majors wife on the MIT team and she had
you know said I can't speak to it now
because she was kind of the delays on to
all the families I can't speak to it now
but I just want you to know that
something happened last week that was
very significant and your you know your
husbands and sons what they did is you
know was incredible and you know all of
all a mother thinks is well you know bad
stuff is going down and so she leading
up to that knock she was on edge she was
on edge that entire deployment but even
more so after that email came and you
know I think that is she tried to every
morning when she woke up she sent him an
email he an email back but she sent him
an email every day she was sending
another care package that probably
wasn't getting to him who's getting to
you know Fallujah but where he was he
wasn't having care packages dropped at
his door but it was like those were the
things she had to do to like process
while he was there like this is what's
going to get me through and that Sunday
I think there there's something about
the fact that you know she woke up that
morning and just said I want to have
people over like it wasn't it was
there's no plan around it and she was a
planner so but that morning she woke up
and said Tom let's have people over so
you imagine all these different
scenarios all these different not
that people get and you know you see
mine you're gonna see Heather's and
Amy's in the book as well but imagine a
scenario where the mother and father
opening the door and there's 30 people
in the house you know they're to have a
family barbecue and I remember when I
walked in that door I could see smoke
coming off the grill because my dad had
walked to answer the door and left all
the meat on the grill and it's out there
like on fire and I you know and it was
like it was pure pandemonium like my
people nobody knows what to do and
people are just literally running around
a house like screaming all the women are
just like screaming like there is no
sanity in this room and I think that's
why my dad's just like I'm gonna stand
out in this driveway you know with with
Colonel Gardner because he's just like
and then the rest is like all these
women and people are coming up like what
do you need I'm like what do I need like
what kind of question is that
I don't know I don't even know what what
is up right now you know but that
chaotic scene is something that that
plays out a lot in my mind over and over
you know what time of day was it it was
like 1 o'clock in the afternoon you know
it was like come up for a Sunday
barbecue and you know aunts and uncles
are there my mom my dad siblings must
you know some of my dad's siblings all
my mom's siblings my grandmother it was
my cousins you know it was just that and
and my mom was always like kind of the
person like coming to my home you know
let's do something but just to have
those people there when that moment took
place yeah it's yeah I remember turning
as I turn to walk in the door I turn and
it was my my little cousins and it's my
dad's sister man Susan she was standing
there with my godson and her two other
kids and they were standing on like the
step going to the back of the house and
she's just trying to console these
little kids
who grew up with Travis I mean literally
grew up with him and she's just trying
and I'm just like you you can't even you
can't even play that scene out in a
movie you know I mean you can't even
capture what what it was you um you tell
you talk about that scene and then and
then you say this in all the chaos and
furious movement I locked eyes with my
grandmother who was seated alone in a
wheelchair in the dining room tears
streaming down her cheeks she was
receiving neither comfort nor attention
from anyone my heart broke in that
instant I'll never forget that image the
rest of the day is a blur I floated
between feelings of painful shock and
dark emptiness when I woke the next
morning I remembered what it felt like
coming out of anesthesia from an
operation I'd had in college first one
eyelid opened cautiously then the next
but my body remained frozen my mind was
already churning going over the details
of the previous day and coming to terms
with the unalterable fact that my best
friend and brother was dead this marked
the first of what turned out to be many
anxiety-ridden morning's that would
follow every day I would slowly and
warily transition from sleep to
consciousness hoping that my
overwhelming anxiety wouldn't make
another appearance but it always did
did you ever have the you ever wake up
in the morning and forget for like three
seconds what had happened no I I didn't
it was actually more like as soon as
soon as I opened my eyes tears I would
be crying like if I was awake I was
either like non-functional just like you
know or I was crying and it's and I
would say for a good month I woke up and
I'm like oh my gosh I think so every day
for the rest of my life I'm gonna wake
up crying you know you you're like you
you go through these phases like okay
this is the new normal I will wake up
crying every day and I honestly could
not wait every night to fall sleep
because the only time I wasn't in pain
was when I was sleeping so it was just
like how quickly can my body and and in
those moments it's not easy to sleep
right so sleep didn't come very easily
so I was so thankful when my body would
let me sleep and you know that was the
only time I was necessarily forgetting
I've experienced like when something
really bad happens like when I've lost
friends and I wake up in the morning and
for like three-set literally three
seconds
you know the alarm clock goes off and I
you know shut off the alarm clock and I
and I and everything is like totally
normal for like for three seconds and
then I take two steps out of my bed and
boom I get hit Oh
now you all go to meet Travis as he is
flown home they were going to the book
of the greeting at Dover was
gut-wrenching my parents and I were
plagued by questions in those early days
that were difficult to ignore who was
Travis with when he died what happened
was it instant slowly the answers
started to unfold we learned that Travis
wasn't actually scheduled to be out on
the mission the day that he was killed
instead a fellow marine was slated for
the patrol but he wasn't feeling up to a
Travis who had been assigned to do some
humanitarian work at a local Iraqi
school offered to take his place during
the course of the patrol Travis and his
team of Marines were ambushed a
firefight erupted and they were quickly
pinned down taking fire from three sides
Travis seeing his Navy corpsman shot and
lying wounded in the middle of the road
immediately ran out of the line of fire
to carry his colleague to safety as the
ambush intensified Travis again entered
the line of fire to pull another wounded
marine back to safety in a covered
position then Travis moved out to take
on the ambush that was now overwhelming
his Patrol undaunted by the onslaught he
fired his m203 grenade launcher taking
out an enemy position and then expended
a firestorm of rounds at the other
positions before running out of
ammunition
his efforts pushed the enemy back and
changed the entire momentum of the
ambush ultimately saving the lives of
his entire Patrol it was then that
Travis was shot by a sniper and
immediately the enemy began to pull back
his teammates quickly grabbed him and
provided what emergency medical care
they could he was rushed back to camp
Fallujah where he is pronounced dead by
the medical staff that had worked
feverishly to try and save him there's
no part of that story that doesn't sound
just like my brother offering to take
the worst assignment to help a friend in
need that was Travis thinking about the
safety of others before ever considering
his own that was Travis to seeing the
dismal odds that didn't bow
well for him and choosing to grit his
teeth and answer a fire with more fire
anyway also Travis my brother was a
protector and a warrior in every sense
of those terms I certainly felt it as
his sister and I'm proud to know that
his fellow Marines got to experience it
too when I learned that he'd been killed
by a bullet I was nervous I wouldn't be
able to stomach the sight of him in an
open casket my mind imagined the worst
I was shocked then when the lid of the
casket was raised at the viewing to see
my brother looking as though he were
sleeping peacefully just as I'd
remembered him I approached the coffin
and rubbed his head as I'd done a
hundred times before from the time he
was a child
Travis would always sported a buzz cut
and as I felt the surface of his freshly
cut hair with my fingertips I thought
yep that's Travis's head
that was Travis yeah and his it's like
his whole life was leading to this
moment where he needed to do something
beyond what is expected of a human being
to do I think you know when you look
back at his childhood I think he was
doing things that were beyond what a ten
year old child was supposed to do or
what a 15 year old kid was supposed to
do or you know it was like and they were
small moments right in the whole scheme
of things but they ultimately prepared
him for that last day I was uh after
Mikey monster got killed and we came
home and I was talking to Mikey's sister
and he was she she was just she just
said yeah she said when I found out what
happened I wasn't even remotely
surprised at all yeah she's like oh he
jumped on a grenade and saved three of
his friends she's like that
that's exactly she's like I don't want
to know to say that I knew that this
would happen but she said this is no
surprise at all yeah
going back to the book I stood by a side
all day greeting friends and family who
had taken the time to pay their respects
one of Travis's best friends and
roommate at the Naval Academy Brendan
Looney was unable to make the funeral he
was in San Diego attending the basic
underwater demolition SEAL school the
training program required for Navy SEALs
leaving to attend the services on the
East Coast would have surely meant
relinquishing his chance to become a
seal officer but Brendan's girlfriend at
the time Amy who had also been close to
Travis did come to say her final
goodbyes
I remember Amy walking up to the casket
and bursting into tears I knew the loss
cut her deeply as well it was a
physically and mentally exhausting day
and as much as I could hardly bear the
idea of standing by that casket one
minute longer after hours of doing so I
also didn't want to imagine that time
coming to an end I knew that after the
last person knelt down to say a prayer
in front of Travis the funeral director
was going to close that casket forever
and that would be it I'd never seen my
brother's face again I rubbed his head
one last time and felt my heart sinking
because my father gently pulled me away
after the funeral the burial and the
celebration of his life that followed I
remember sitting on the back stairs
outside my parents home the same place
where I had sought solace in the chaos
after first hearing of his death the
winter had melted away in a beautiful
spring day had sprung up in its place in
the weeks and months that followed I
often found myself outside crouched on
that stair and then in those stairs in
that same position time was passing life
was moving on I was watching it happen
but I was not participating in it
I felt bitterness towards the people who
could return to their normal lives jobs
and families while I sat on the same
stair in the same red sweatshirt
terrified of what might come next I you
know when you when you were talking
about like saying oh this is just the
way it's gonna be from now on I'm just
gonna be crying all the time and I had
somebody asked me about you know when is
this when does this end this like well
how do you get through this and the way
I tried to explain it is by saying when
you first experienced something
devastating like this you're gonna get
hit with these waves and the waves are
going to be really powerful really
strong and they're gonna come really
often and what's scary about them is be
by the time you're 28 years old or 20
years old or whatever however old you
are you've learned to control your
emotions and all of a sudden you're in a
situation we don't have control anymore
mm-hmm and it seems like like you said
that's just the way it's going to be
from now on and then what I've noticed
is over time those waves they start to
lose some strength they're just not as
strong as they were and over time those
waves they separate and they get further
and further apart and what happens this
is what I thought of when I read this
this part that you wrote is you know the
closer you are to the person the
stronger those waves are and the longer
it takes for that calm to approach so
when you see other people that are
already kind of have found some calm
again and they're moving on it makes you
it can make you mad totally I you know
they have that this twelve stages of
grief I couldn't I couldn't name all
twelve stages and in followed but like I
know angers up there and I felt anger
you know and it was just like and it was
anger at everyone else like screw you
guys
you know we're worse we're just we're
here we're living it and you're living
their lives on the flip side you know
having some perspective like thank you
for being there for us thank you for
doing what you did thank you for leaving
your job for a week to support my family
you know you don't have that mindset
when you're in it you're like oh you're
going back to work you're you're flying
back like what do you mean like no
you're all supposed to be here and you
know we're all gonna live together in
this house and and support each other
yeah you you think yourself life is not
going to go on the way it was ever yeah
and and that was this that was the
scariest part so was this this idea of
like it was that initial walk through
the door and then then everything takes
over you know you go into this autopilot
of like we've got to plan for everything
so it's the anticipation of being at
Dover but that anticipation comes with a
level of excitement isn't the right word
but like I can't wait till that coffin
comes on the plane off the plane
Darrius he's now with us you know and
it's these small steps and it's like
okay next is the viewing I can't wait to
be able to see my brother and then it's
like work
in that casket and it's like another
thing you know you walked through that
door the caskets closing the funeral
mass happens everyone comes back you've
got hundreds and hundreds of people at a
reception and then it's like that last
bag of trash is taken out by the
neighbor and they say bye and you're
like oh crap
now we actually really have to think
about what this means you know because
you're just kind of going through this
process by the way I failed to mention
this so far I'm not reading the whole
book and so if there's some things that
are jumping around or whatever that's
why because I'm not here to do an audio
version of this book but that's why I'm
reading chunks of it but you've got all
kinds of detail in there that I'm not
going over and connecting these chunks
that I'm reading so that's why people
should just buy the book so I haven't
said that yet but if there's anything
that seems jumpy that's why it is jump
because I'm jumping around from section
to section you continue on here it was
hard to believe that only weeks before
I'd been so happy bliss free blissfully
ignorant of how my life would be cruelly
abruptly and permanently changed I
remember sitting in my kitchen two weeks
before Travis died I was watching my
baby girl all nine and a half months old
pull herself up to stand on uncertain
and wobbly legs she stood with her
chubby hands on the screen door she
stood next to our dog pup and giggled
excitedly as she peered outside and
watched a bunny rabbit hop around the
backyard life is so completely perfect I
remember thinking at that moment
I was a happy new mom had a fantastic
relationship with my husband business
was good and Travis would be back in
time for the grand opening of my second
store I felt holy in control and at
peace to this day that peaceful feeling
sometimes comes back to me for a moment
when life feels effortless my mind is at
ease and all seems right in the world
but now it dissolves in an instant in
fact as soon as I experience that kind
of
I become terrified what terrible tragedy
is going to shatter this picture of
perfect peace I asked myself I still
wonder if the sense of calm I
experienced that day at being a harp had
been a harbinger of the doom to come I
worried that I was foolish for not
having recognized it for what it was
all the signs of catastrophe were right
in front of me how could I have been so
blind this train of thought is of course
completely paranoid and insane so do you
feel that now to this day yeah you know
I I do I don't have many times where
life feels effortless anymore but you
know I I remember that feeling I had
that day in my house I remember that
feeling so vividly just it was this wave
that came over me where I was like oh my
gosh like this is what a great life I
have you know I'm like looking at my new
daughter and I'm just and and I think I
just gotten off the phone with Travis
like a day or two prior and and our
conversations had nothing to do with
what he was doing in Iraq he's like
talking to me about you know what what
kind of men's brands did you get for the
store you know is there cool stuff and
and so it was just like this super
peaceful feeling and I lived up in to
that point not really fearful of
anything and you know I I certainly
today I'm certainly afraid of I'm afraid
when I get a random call I'm afraid when
my husband calls me twice in a row you
know those things can set me into a
different place they can they can
certainly you know I my favorite show
was my favorite show was Big Love that
was an HBO series on like polygamy and
it was really popular when scripted
series when around that time
and I love the show was God who was the
guy who was in it he's since passed away
but anyway great show do Paxton it was
Bill Paxton yeah yeah it was it was a
great show and I remember watching that
show and and these are the things that
you don't realize are gonna happen so
I'm watching the show and it's like this
series finale and it was those little
things where I was like this is post
Travis's death and I'm like well you
know big loves on that's something I can
enjoy I'm gonna watch this season finale
and I'm watching the finale and on the
finale like the head-head polygamist get
shot and he had shot on the street and
what watching him get shot it sent me
into a full-blown panic attack it was
such a visceral reaction that I wasn't
expecting that it stunned me and I was
like oh my god I I can't see that I mean
my my five-year-old walks around he's
got a little like pistol that was that
was Dave's my husband's and he brought
it my mother-in-law found it and she
brought it back about a month ago and
it's the cutest little thing with the
holster and I can't be around Travis
holding it my little Travis holding it
unlike David there's something about
like guns now you know and there's
seeing them pointed being shot like it
sends me in a in a bad place you know
and it's it's those sort of things that
you don't you don't realize until a
little bit after the fact that okay
these are the residual effects and some
of them go away and some of them don't
you know and some of them just are a
part of who you are now
and I'm I'm definitely a a jumpier
person you know like I hear something
I'm like what what happened you know
where before I was not like that I was
kind of like I heard something you know
you talked a little bit about that more
here you say the fear and paranoia that
follow in the wake of grief can create a
tremendous roadblock it stunts our
personal growth and darkens our overall
sense of well-being some people respond
to unexpected and trying situations with
passive acquiescence and others with
fire and fury I responded by heightening
my vigilance after Travis's death I
found myself compelled to be wary I was
always on the lookout for the next great
tragedy to befall me this hurled me down
some very dark and troublesome paths
from panic attacks to self-destructive
behaviors but also led me to some
amazing gifts like recovering my sense
of humor and living with intention what
self-destructive behaviors did you pick
up I mean I think you know
self-destructive in a way that you know
I stopped kind of taking care of myself
um you know you I I go into the next
place where I'm talking about you know I
decide to run a marathon but I'm running
a marathon smoking a pack of cigarettes
a day and you know I'm drinking a lot
and I'm just kind of like I'm gonna do
this but on the same token you know this
is kind of Who I am now you know and you
know with the with that that hyper sense
of paranoia you know I really went into
some these ideas of and I and I I know
what I know the reasoning behind it if I
can look back and like psychoanalyze
myself when Travis was in Iraq I was not
worried about him and when he was there
the first time when he was there the
second time even though I knew the
second deployment was different I was
aware of that because my husband told me
he's like hey this is gonna be different
you know I've had conversations with
your brother but I had no fear of my
brother being in Iraq it was this notion
of more than anything you think about
like these crazy stories right you know
I
or like you know a icicle falling off a
garage and like impaling a woman on her
head right and it's like these totally
crazy stories and you're like that's so
crazy
well I mean it's never gonna happen to
you right it's like the plane-crash
theory like we all fly on planes but you
know you tell your kids planes aren't
planes don't crash you know you're not
going to play in the crashes so you
don't think about that happening to you
and that maybe it was a defense
mechanism but that's how I got through
Travis being in Iraq I wasn't you know I
didn't show any fear I didn't show any
eye and I didn't even have any fear it
wasn't that I didn't show it I really
didn't have it I let those emotions all
go so then when it did happen it was
like I guess when you do this idea of
like preparing right where you're it's
almost like I knew this was coming like
you hear people like I knew it I knew it
right like I had no idea and so to have
something shock your system that much I
think it kind of rewires you where
you're kind of waiting for that next
shock to the system and you know you
lead on throughout the book and I've had
other things that have that have
happened since where I know like the no
one is void of having something happen
you know whether it's random in nature
I've had a lot of random crappy things
happen to me you know over the last
several years I guess it's it's similar
again this is something I just talked
about with Jim Shirley who was on the
last podcast was in Vietnam and the
range of level of fear that guys have
going into combat there's some people
that are scared they're like they think
they're gonna die right and there's some
people that are kind of like that that
will actually not happen to me like I'm
I'm not gonna die and that was kind of
his attitude was you're that you're
you're thinking oh that's yeah he like
he volunteered to go to Vietnam
he wasn't like I'm volunteering to go
Vietnam and I might die he was like I'm
volunteering to go to Vietnam and I'm
gonna go do my job and and so I guess
it's no surprise for some people on the
family side to think well
yeah that's not gonna happen to my loved
one yeah I I've never really asked my
parents this I don't think my parents
ever fought anything would ever happen
to me ever you know I thought they think
they just thought I was just overdoing
and guess whatever part of that is
because I I kind of inculcated them to
just not never knowing what I was doing
ever and I was in for a long time and
before the war started I had already
been in for 13 years so they never knew
that I was jumping out of airplanes or
doing whatever I was doing and so when
the war started is still going on
deployments like I'd always gone I'd
been
I'd gone on deployments I'd gone on five
deployments before I went to Iraq so
that to them they were saying oh he's
going on another deployment we'll hear
from him in six months or whatever my
wife maybe the same thing but until like
when when I was in Ramadi and my wife
was at home and she was going to my guys
funerals and when that happens every
single family member that's there is
thinking that the person that was killed
could easily be you know my husband my
brother my son now you talk a little bit
about just this idea of grief the fact
is grief will transform you and you've
got will italicized which I think is
important because you're saying listen
like you because I think that's what I
think that's the the discovery that you
made in that statement is you're
thinking hey I can get through this and
everything is I'll be back to the way
things were and you're saying no the
fact is grief will transform you whether
you are grieving the loss of an identity
that you once had or the loss of a loved
one at some point you will look in the
mirror and see someone you simply don't
recognize staring back at you it is
inevitable maybe you should maybe you'll
be proud of what you see and maybe
you'll be ashamed at some point I bet
you bebo I bet you will be both the most
important thing you can tell yourself is
that
you get the last word only you can
determine how your experiences will
change you and only you can be held
accountable for that transformation so
these are these are powerful things I
wrote a book and I guess I talked about
an attitude of extreme ownership of
taking ownership of what's going on and
you know there's always someone that
wants to make different points or trying
to I'll be positive about it there's
people that want to that people that
want to test the theory right taking
ownership and so one of the things that
can happen is you know hey I got cancer
that's not my fault how do I take
ownership of that and it's like well
you're right you can't take ownership of
the fact that you got cancer you take
ownership of how you respond to it right
and I just was out with working with a
group of people and one of the guys had
cancer and he was like hey I started
listening to the podcast and he's like I
listened to your podcast for seven hours
a day every day the whole time I was in
the hospital which makes me feel good
about having 500 hours or less
but that's what he did he took ownership
of how he responded right and that's
what you're saying here look you're
gonna something's gonna happen there's
gonna be changes but you do have what do
you say though you get the last word
right well I think you know one of the
things that I have people still to this
day say you know and and and I'm 12
years out from the loss of my brother
seven years out from the loss of my mom
and nine years out from the loss of
Brendan right and and people will say
you know when does when you stop
grieving and I'll even have people that
have newly lost someone like explaining
this grief process like when is it going
to end
and I'm very clear to tell them it
doesn't it never ends I'm not going to
say don't worry you know in a year it's
over because everybody's journey is
their own but the fact of the matter is
is that I entered into my if you want to
call it grief journey in in a way that
wasn't best for me right I wasn't it was
a it was a process and now when you look
at like talking about looking in the
mirror and are you the person you want
to be like when I look in the mirror
today I'm the person that I wish Travis
saw when he was alive like that's and so
that for me is like that was my wake-up
I'm like okay so this is what the grief
of my brother has done to me it's
actually allowed me to become the person
I should have been when he was here I
was I had a guy in the podcast his name
was Tom five years he was he was in
World War two Korea and Vietnam and he
he was a Purple Heart recipient from all
those Wars and he was a battalion
commander in Vietnam and I was talking
to him about it and like I asked him you
know basically you know I think I asked
him how many casualties did you take or
how many guys did you lose as a
battalion commander and so this is I
don't know 50 or 60 years later and he
got choked up and when that happened I
thought to myself oh the emotions that I
have they're never gonna go away
yeah and that's just the way it is and
there's nothing wrong with that you know
the waves get the waves get more
separation between them over time but
those waves can hit you yeah at any time
and I think you know what I find now is
the further you get out the waves
actually
comment like really inopportune times so
I'm not an incredibly emotional person
to begin with that bout of the first
month after Travis's death was probably
the most crying I've ever done in my
entire life but it was like it was an
involuntary response like I could there
was no that's just what it was and I if
I was out in public I had on the biggest
sunglasses you could possibly find cuz I
did not I get uncomfortable when people
see me emotional and so I was I had to
tried to cover it and but now today you
know the way those waves come it it's it
could be something so small that someone
says or something I see and it doesn't
matter where I am and it's just like oh
my god and it kind of like takes your
breath away takes you back to that place
and you know I do a lot of public
speaking and and and I share Travis's
story and and everyone's like I don't
know how you do that without breaking
down and I'm like listen that's not the
time for me to break down like I'm there
to do a job I'm there to share that
story and make sure that you hear that
story but if you think for one second
that there aren't times I'm driving in
the car and a song comes on or I'm out
on a run or I'm sitting there looking at
my kids and you know yeah that still
happens and and it and it doesn't come
as as often but like you said you know
5060 years out a service member talking
about his friends like that's never
going to go away and nor would I want it
to exactly exactly you continue on here
like anyone who's received a jarring
knock at the door literal or figurative
and that's what's important and you
again this since I'm jumping around this
book you know that there's the
metaphorical knock at the door that a
servicemembers family can receive but
that knock in the door can be anything
right anything that is unexpected in
your life and everyone's gonna get them
in your life you're gonna get a knock at
the door that you want to do what your
mom did which is slam the door and don't
let it come in but it's comin
I've been to the darkest deepest and
ugliest corners of my mind and I've
learned a thing or two I don't hope to
spare you the hurt or pain that comes
with a knock I'll read that again I
don't hope to spare you the hurt or pain
that comes with the knock I don't think
that I could I only hope to share the
lessons I learned in the process the
ones that have the power to transform
you in all the right ways and remind you
that you are not alone
so yeah you you're not saying that you
can make the pain go away it's gonna
hurt but there's there's steps you can
take to move through that hurt that make
more sense
like you said looking back yeah yeah
this book is all built on perspective
I'll tell you that you know I mean I I
couldn't wrote this book even five years
ago you know I mean it it took 12 years
to be able to say okay I'm ready to put
pen to paper and listen I'm no expert
but I've got a lot of experience and
grief you know so I'm gonna kind of
share share my thoughts on that well it
helps anytime you can have just anytime
you can see something unfold for someone
else it makes you able to better handle
it yourself just 100% that's why I read
war books all the time so I was able to
try and figure out what was happening in
combat even if I'd never seen it before
I'd seen it before mm-hmm you say this
in the early days after Travis was
killed my decision-making was more
impulsive than rational impulsive
decisions can be catastrophic and a few
of mine have been but they've also been
a great way for me to channel my nervous
energy I think subconsciously I believed
that as long as I was doing something
anything then I would have to then I
wouldn't have to acknowledge the intense
pain that was overtaking my spirit and
fighting to get out two weeks before
Travis was killed he called home from
Iraq I wanted I want to run the Marine
Corps Marathon he told my dad that's
great trav my dad responded and I want
you to run it with
he finished my father was then in his
early 50s and in solid shape but this
was no small request after running the
Marine Corps Marathon a couple times
when he was younger my dad had retired
his marathon shoes forever he thought
but he wasn't about to say no to his son
fighting a war thousands of miles away
let's do what he replied in mid-may when
the funeral services were over and my
parents extended family and friends were
gathered in the living room my dad
remembered his promise to Travis I'm
still gonna run that marathon he
proclaimed to the quiet gathering of
distraught dumbstruck family members all
run to Tom said Chris my dad's youngest
brother I'm in echoed his wife my Aunt
Susan one by one people picked up their
heads hardened their gazes and joined
him pretty soon every single person in
that room had committed to 26.2 miles in
honor of Travis I was conveniently
engrossed in a thread on the carpet when
I felt he doesn't Ayers of eyes landing
intently on my face I looked up now I
had been an athlete in college but that
was almost five years earlier I had
given birth to Maggie only ten months
before and I hadn't run so much as a 5k
and ages but those stairs were burning a
hole right through my skin and
thankfully my bullheadedness kicked in
all right I'll do it I said I mean how
hard could it be and then you you get
done with your first training run at the
end of that first one-mile run wheezing
forcefully and doubled over in pain I
gave myself a little pat on the back
good job Ryan you did today's run you're
done now go home drink some water and
chill but make damn sure you show up for
tomorrow's run and that's how it went
every day for four and a half months no
matter how slow ugly are painful to run
might have been I completed it there was
no 26.2 mile run ahead of me oh there
was no 26.2 mile ahead of me there was
only today as the proverb says there's
only one way to eat an elephant one bite
at a time so you talked about your
training I thought it was cool you
you've got Travis's iPod yeah how
awesome was that it was awesome yeah
came back in his footlocker and I'm like
all right and he was so into music and
we both shared like a deep love of music
we went to concerts together all the
time and so that was like exciting
I didn't have an iPod at the time so it
came back and it was what and I'm like
gosh I hope I can get this thing working
and you know plugged it in and I was
like all right there we go
it's so crazy to think that these
digital memories of people I mean and
even I mean today today the digital
memories of people are gonna be crazy
yeah I mean it's just you're gonna have
all these images and videos and writing
and posts and all this stuff for people
yeah and like even just something like
that what is it 12 years ago
you know this iPod you know you fast you
could rewind another 20 years behind
that there's no iPod there's no there's
you might had a mixtape I guess well I
look at - it's interesting like and I
remember talking to Travis on his first
appointment I'm like let me set you up a
myspace profile I'm not doing that I'm
like come on and and you know so he had
no imprint on social media at all but
just a few years later you know when
Brendan was killed I was Facebook
friends with Brendan Brendan had a
Facebook page you know and it was just
that that's small that small time but to
have that iPod the coolest thing about
it for me is that it wasn't just like it
was Travis's iPod I'm like this is what
he was taking in when he was in Iraq
yeah for sure you know so like I'm
listening to it and I just felt it felt
like such a deep connection with where
he had been and you know what's so cool
about that what you just said you even
realized how right you are because like
I had my iPod in Iraq my last
appointment which was 2006 and those
songs like what however many songs were
on my iPad at the time like whatever 215
songs or whatever it was yeah whenever I
hear those songs right now I'm right
back I mean I was 100% listening to the
same songs over and over and over and
over again
yeah and I'm and I'm now brought back I
hear any of those songs on brought back
to train him for that marathon that's
where they bring me back to so you talk
about the training and then here we go
as the big date approached this is for
the marathon my family and I headed to
Washington through which the marathon
course runs the night before the race we
held a dinner for our team which by now
had grown to nearly a hundred people
aunts uncles cousins friends neighbors
lacrosse and wrestling butter buddies
fellow Marines and Naval Academy grad
all of them were participating to honor
my brother at dinner at a hotel we
invited a few people including Brendan
Looney who is to say a few words
Brendan stood solemnly at the microphone
he stared he started in about how Travis
had been a brother to him and how he
couldn't believe he was gone he was a
great friend Brendan said I'll never
forget him and I miss him he'd been
choking back tears and finally his voice
broke I have to get out of this room I
thought I simply couldn't watch this
tough Navy SEAL breakdown as he
remembered my brother it was too much I
slipped out of the hotel and found
myself gulping in the cold fall air
outside my head was spinning and I
couldn't help but feel that I was
learning for the first time that Travis
was gone forever I lit a cigarette it
had been on and off habit of mine over
the years one that Travis had always
chastised me about maybe one day I'll
write a book about what not to do when
running a marathon chain-smoking the
night before the race would certainly
make the list but it's not even the
worst transgression I've committed
fortunately for you this isn't a book
about endurance training it's a book
about grief which perhaps isn't so
different the key to navigating grief
I've found is to have the courage to
allow it to transform you same same
theme like accepting the fact that it's
gonna make you different I've had to
remind myself time and time again we're
only human
we can only take so much don't be so
hard on yourself when you take one step
forward and several steps back you made
it this far you got up today and put one
foot in front of the other you completed
today's run go home relax and get ready
for tomorrow's now you get into the
marathon which is a great story I'm
jumping ahead a little bit here but got
to mile 19 and I still had 7.2 miles to
complete at this point the wheels had
all become off my brain was no longer
able to bully my body into behaving my
knees my ankles my arches everything was
rebelling I had slowed to a walk and
began to debate with myself bent began
the debate with myself that any distant
run distance runner knows well 18 miles
is great
you should be proud of yourself there's
no shame in stopping here you just lost
your brother for God's sake did anyone
really expect you to get this far call
it now and leave with your dignity and
your joints intact so you're having that
the quitters conversation totally the
quitters conversation you're having it
but you're not a quitter so I made one
last-ditch effort in a net I reached
into my fanny pack and rifled through my
unused power gels and energy beans until
my fingers rested on the mass card with
Travis's face on it November 19th 1980
to April 29th 2007 26 years old I
gripped it tightly and offered a silent
prayer this is it Travis the Marine
Corps Marathon course ends at the US
Marine Corps War Memorial a statue based
on the iconic picture of six Marines
struggling to raise a flagpole on the
island of Iwo Jima during World War two
it's an incredibly powerful sight and
when you come upon it you feel every bit
as tired and as strong as those men
huddled together appear to be as they
raised the American flag I didn't care
if my leg fell off in that very moment I
was not walking up that hill I hustled
into a full sprint bounded over crushed
plastic cups and past exhausted runners
somehow I felt my legs were fresh in
reality I was probably every bit the
Frankenstein I had appeared to be at
Mile 19 just an hour older what I
actually looked like I can't say for
sure and I'd rather not imagine but I
pushed forward and grabbed aunt Susan's
hand as together we crossed the finish
line
then I collapsed I can honestly say that
I'm a different person because of that
race pushing myself through that
training and navigating the emotional
strain and physical stress taught me a
lot about myself and even more about
grief it took me years to process my
brother's death and years more to
organize my thoughts around what wisdom
I could possibly gain from it it's only
after more than a decade of reflection
that I can share what I now know
and here you kind of lay some of these
out first what you don't know can't hear
you can't hurt you which is an
interesting concept what what you don't
know can't hurt you wait hear me out
I know this advice is usually given
sarcastically and that can be for good
reason but consider for a moment the
wisdom in that phrase sometimes being
naive is a blessing if I had known the
physical mental and emotional toll that
the race would have taken on me I
wouldn't run it I would have become
paralyzed with fear and self-doubt and
my eyes would have remained forever
fixed on that thread in the carpet but
fear and self-doubt often keep us from
knowing our own strength and that's
something we simply can't risk if I had
never run that risk race I would never
have discovered what I was capable of
achieving preparation and training are
great tools they provide us with
confidence to dream as big as we want to
but without a healthy dose of fearless
ignorant we might never bother dreaming
at all it's interesting advice yeah I
like it it's advice I still follow to
this day I mean it's it's kind of I am I
will say you know pre Travis didn't
really live with fear right but I didn't
really do anything to be fearful of and
today I definitely have those like I
said you know I'm on edge I'm always on
edge but I'm also on edge in a way that
I'm like what's next like I'm like
hungry for what's next
and I the things that I have done over
the last 12 years I don't even know if I
could pick five of them that I would
have done pre 2007 or frankly had any
interest in I mean had Travis come home
nobody you see Travis placed a call from
my rack to my dad to say run the
marathon he wasn't calling me to say run
the marathon that wasn't even a thought
in his head because he knew that there
was no way I would even consider running
a marathon
and I've just kind of approached things
as like
I'm just gonna do it you know what's the
worst that can happen and and you do you
have this like what's the my brother is
dead
what's the worst that can happen you
know I don't make it I don't make I
don't finish the race and you know and
it and that was 12 years ago and that
was my I remember saying I'm gonna do
that finish this marathon and then I'm
gonna be able to say I ran a marathon
and I'm and people like oh you're gonna
get the bug once you run one you're and
I was like I never got the bug I'm like
nope I have my checkmark I can say when
people say oh we're in compare I'm like
yeah I ran it you know and but I don't
know what changed but you know Here I am
again like 12 years later and I'm rockin
the Marine Corps Marathon in a week and
140 pounds
oh god no 20 pounds 20 pounds yeah okay
yeah yeah I said and this is a person
who's never rocked before so I go well I
we have a fantastic partnership with go
rock the GORUCK community and so I get
to meet the founder of cook go rock have
you ever met Jason McCarthy I have not
he's great guy West Point grad and he
just has this fabulous community I
didn't understand it but I knew that the
people connected with the Travis Manion
foundation loved rocking so I'm like all
for it
so they asked me to do this promotional
video with Jason and to highlight our
partnership and we're in Georgia and
we're they're filming us and we're
walking around the lake and he's like
let's get Ryan a rucksack and so I put
this rucksack oh my god this setup
pretty big-time I mean the rucksack had
like newspaper in it so I'm just like
okay so oh my god this is funny this and
he's explaining the theory of rucking is
like the nice thing about it is like
your pace is always a conversational
pace and you know and I'm like I like
that like I like that I can sit here and
talk to you and we're exercising and
he's talked about the benefits of it
from a child perspective like you bring
your kids out because they're gonna be
walking slow but you just put more
weight on and you're getting a workout
so conceptually I'm like okay
well later that night we were at a
summit we had like a hundred veterans
through the trans man foundation we'd
brought for like leadership training and
later that night everybody's by the
bonfire and we're a few drinks in and
everybody's talking about oh I'm rocking
the marathon and and it was like another
one of those scenes instead of in my
parents living room I'm behind BIA you
know around a bonfire with a bunch of
veterans and they're like it's like I'm
gonna I'm gonna wreck the marathon I'm
gonna and MIT was like came to me and
I'm like I'm rockin the marathon and I
woke up the next day and I was like yeah
I don't know fun rockin the marathon but
then I get back to Philadelphia and a
rucksack shows up at my front door and I
was like oh crap you're rockin right I
guess I'm not gonna marathon yeah it's I
was uh I was talking to Travis Mills
yeah I love trying
Travis is awesome yeah we were talking
about you know I was talking to him uh
like why didn't you and he was a total
stud in high school football you sent
records like he's and he's just like a
beast of a human an athlete and you know
I said to him why don't you go to like
Special Forces or why don't you go to
Ranger School he's like I didn't know if
I could make it and I was like oh that's
funny
because I as a young 18 year old kid
when I do in the Navy I had enough of
this right here I had enough of what do
you say ignorance fearless ignorance
yeah you know I was I was like an
average athlete yeah and I was like all
SEAL training I'll make it through
whatever you know and here's a total
stud that was he was like I didn't know
if I could make I was like I'm you
didn't have it he didn't have enough
fearless ignorance yeah but um yeah so
the same thing and and I find that a lot
with these young kids that there's some
kids that want to be seals but I mean I
have people come to my gym here and they
look I really wanted to go seals but I
don't know if I could make it I'm always
thinking man you're in better shape than
I ever was right but you gotta have a
little bit of fearless ignorance yeah a
little bit yeah I mean hey I'm I'm using
my fearless ignorance again to rock this
marathon I'm just you know and but but
that also comes coupled with no way
how hard a marathon is so Krista who's
in a lot of this book you know she's
I've convinced her to ruck the marathon
with me she's never done a marathon
before and we did 18 miles last week and
she's like I feel great like this feels
great I feel like I could keep going and
I'm like you don't understand this that
lasts 7.2 miles that puts you over the
edge I'm like she has the fearless igner
and she has no idea got it right where
you want yeah I'm like I know so I'm
like I'd rather be in your shoes right
now here's your next piece of advice
from this section second embrace your
support system relationships are
everything friends family and loved ones
can get us through our darkest and
saddest moments we just need to let them
our friends and families feed our wild
ambitions they gently and lovingly
protect us from our own self-destructive
habits they list lift us up when we
can't go another step with a loving
support system we can afford to be a
little naive
be bold be fearless but don't do it
alone you are human and you are one
person allow yourself to be carried
forward by those who love you and then
your last piece of advice in this
section and finally don't wait I beg you
please don't wait I had no idea how
tough I was why did I wait until my
brother was dead to find out my only
regret of that marathon in 2007 was that
it didn't take place in 2006 you know
who would have loved to run and train
with me Travis something like that which
required focus and discipline was far
more up his alley than mine he would
have been so proud and we would have had
a ball together there are so many things
I wish I could have done together wish
we could have done together I'm not the
same woman he knew when he was alive I'm
better I'm stronger why did I wait for
him to disappear before I became the
woman I wanted to be don't wait don't we
continuing on in 2007 if you were to
graph my emotions for that year you
would produce an interesting line a
fairly stable higher horizontal line of
contentment for the beginning of the
year a drastic drop in April when Travis
died then a gradual climb back up toward
happiness until the marathon six months
later I was so grateful to have
something to focus on that helped me put
the pieces of my life back together
after the loss of my brother it was
precisely the medicine I needed but by
winner my line was dropping again the
decline in my happiness and well-being
was persistent steady and interestingly
almost undetectable I of course knew
that my life had been far better when
Travis was in it but I was managing
wasn't I
after all I was getting up going to work
being a mom I was running errands and
knocking out personal goals I was
socializing and even laughing and
finding joy here and there by any
external external de barometer I was
improving I was wounded no doubt but I
was happy but grief is very much an
internal battle it's not kind enough to
play by the rules and it certainly
doesn't register on any emotional
barometer it can be deceptive and
believe it or not
so can you in fact I would wager that no
one can deceive you as effectively as
you can deceive yourself grief pain
sadness these feel like disadvantages
they threaten our survival so naturally
we shed them we convince ourselves we
convince ourselves that they've gone
away this is precisely what I did and
it's amazing what I managed to hide from
myself and for how long
my emotional slope continued to creep
stealthily downward for several years it
continued right under my nose until
Christmas night of 2012 when I reached
rock bottom but the seeds if my
deterioration had been planted several
years before now we've talked about your
brother and obviously had your dad on
the podcast we're gonna talk about your
mom a little bit and this is how you
describe your mom Janet Janet Mannion
was a tough optimistic and focused she
made every decision with self-assurance
as if despite any concerns or doubts
that she may have been harboring the
anxieties the worries they were there of
course they had to be she simply would
not allow them to triumph over her she
had Herculean willpower four years after
Travis's death my mother continued to be
the picture of stalwart strength she
ain't in a way that only a mother who
has buried her son can but she never let
it keep her down it was especially
disorienting for me then when I learned
a few years later that my mother this
pennant of courage for our family had
only eight months to live we got the
news in 2011 four years after Travis's
death a surgery revealed that Stage four
lung cancer had spread throughout her
body eight months after eight months
later a few days before the fifth
anniversary of Travis's death my mother
joined him in heaven and only five years
my only sibling and my mother had died
my family of four had been reduced to
two I was devastated no marathon was
going to make this loss any easier to
bear I had no idea where to turn for
help I simply couldn't stomach the
thought of picking up the pieces once
again I hadn't even collected them all
the first time in the months after my
mother's death on April 24th 2012 I
turned to the methods of coping that had
become familiar to me I threw myself
into my work and into my family's busy
schedule I set small goals losing weight
reading running anything to keep waking
up everyday and moving it had worked
before hadn't it it could work again I
figured I was wrong
you know I think when I look at the
five-year span between Travis and my mom
I kind of I'll say I peaked in terms of
like with that marathon it was like I'm
gonna do this you know and and then from
there it just became this idea like I
talk now like when people asked me does
grief end like no it doesn't but at that
time I didn't know that and so I thought
grief grief was over for me did you have
any was there any indication of what was
gonna what was gonna happen with your
mom no I mean if you looked at my family
dynamic after Travis was killed she was
the Sparta woman that had taken over and
was leading the charge and it was kind
of my dad and I following behind her I
mean I can't put into words the the
strength that she displayed and and now
with three kids of my own I can't even I
can't even fathom it and so you know I
was doing things between those five
years she had started the Travis Manion
foundation and at first my dad and I
looked at it as almost a labor of love
it was like okay well this is good it's
like the small Memorial Fund and we'll
keep her distracted yeah I mean
seriously we had those conversations
like great way for her to channel her
grief to work through things she can
help people locally I mean that's how we
saw it that is that is so funny because
you're sitting there going oh that's
what she's like got a master plan yeah
oh it was like it couldn't looking back
it couldn't have been more short-sighted
on our parts to think that she was just
gonna la-dee-da around town you know and
be like I've got a Memorial Fund like no
I mean she
right away was like we're gonna be one
of the I mean she would say things like
our 9/11 heroes run this was like a 5k
run that we had the year after Travis
was killed 9/11 heroes run it was 300
people in Doylestown Pennsylvania you
know small suburban town outside of
Philadelphia and I was like this is so
cool like great Ron great to have the
community out and my mom comes up and
she's like I want this to be the Susan G
Komen Race for the Cure for our military
community we need one of these in every
city and state across the country and
I'm like and you know my dad and I would
be like okay Janet like like I roll like
why don't we just try to get like a
thousand people at the run next year you
know that would be like a cool goal but
you know you look at where we are today
we've got we just finished our racers 90
runs across the world brought out 60,000
people
I mean Janet wasn't play are there Susan
G Komen Race for the Cure for the
military community you know bringing
awareness to our military and first
responders and so you know I'm watching
her do that
and I joined the foundation in early
2010 and I'm just kind of I mean my
title was executive director my real
title was Janet Mannion's assistant you
know I mean I was her assistant and I
was happy to be that and to play that
role because frankly I had no idea what
I was doing and I'm following behind her
and just kind of it was like you know
she was teaching me you know it's like
it was I was watching everything that
she did I was trying to emulate how she
was doing it she was so bold and
fearless like she would she had no
problem asking anyone for anything and I
was just like God if I can just hang
around her enough to gain some of that
experience and so our time
so limited that I was able to do that
with her till the time she was diagnosed
with cancer and it was another one of
those just like gut punches but it came
in like a different form as opposed to
like knock gone right it comes as my arm
hurts your kid was you know being a pain
in the butt and when I tried to pick her
up she wiggled out of my arm and we're
down at the beach and Oh mom throw some
throw some ice on it
you know and we get back home and she's
like guy my arm still hurts it's not
incredibly swollen or anything like how
many you don't think anything of it and
so it's like a couple days later all
right I think I'm gonna go to get my arm
checked out all right I'll go with you
we go down to our she calls our friend
who's in an orthopedic hey can you run
an x-ray on me I think I might have
broke my arm yeah come on in you know we
left the foundation office we go in they
give her an x-ray and he comes out and I
just you just you knew and he comes out
and goes um so you have a little break
there but I want to send you down to my
friend Penn to take a look at it because
there's you know just to just to get
another look and you know you get
another opinion well all right you just
told me a broke my arm you're not gonna
cast it and I'm like this is weird
so I'll make you an appointment let's
get you down there tomorrow and we show
up at the office and it was my mom my
dad and I and I remember we walk up and
it's like dr. someone so orthopedic
oncologist and we were like well you
know I'm like and I'm like my mom has
bone cancer you know that's all I'm
thinking like what and so she goes into
surgery the next day and you know you
don't know what a diagnosis looks like
it's like she's got a tumor in her arm
okay that's the most random thing I've
ever heard in my life and they're like
well she had a tumor in her arm we
removed it but the tumor didn't didn't
start there so now we have to figure out
like where it came from but that also
means that his
wherever it came from it has spread and
so it's like another and that night my
parents are slated my mom's in a bed at
University of Pennsylvania Hospital and
my parents are supposed to be getting
the Commodore Barry Citizen of the Year
award presented to them by general
Dunford and so my dad and I head to the
event we come back and we get back to
the room and the doctors like yeah it's
started in her lung it's in her brain
it's in her back I mean it was
everywhere and not one symptom at all
like not one symptom she was not smoking
cigarettes while training for a marathon
you know I mean it was it was crazy it
was like how does how does this happen
you know and I've read a lot of studies
on like grief manifestation with stress
and how like your body sometimes can let
go of certain cells when you're
experiencing trauma and I think there's
I mean I have to believe there's
something to say to that
you know Brendan Looney's mom died three
years after he was killed from cancer so
I mean I think the coincidences are are
a lot but you know the doctors tell us
like you've got eight months to live
with treatment if you decide to go to
treatment route it's just gonna help
prolong you we're gonna give you about
eight months my mom never really took
that and was like she didn't do one of
these I've got eight months to live this
is what I'm gonna do
she was just like okay I'm gonna start
my treatments and I'm gonna keep working
so you know you're she's diagnosed with
stage four cancer and she's back in the
office the next day and she's standing
there with a you know a wrap around her
arm where she had just had surgery but
like it was it was a little off-putting
because nothing changed
it wasn't like okay everything changes
now what she was like no we've got a
we've got a job to do
and it wasn't until the very end when
her health started
a bit of a decline that I took on more
of a caretaker role with her but this
was like it was like eight months and
six and a half of those months were just
you would have never known anything was
different so you know she's going to
chemo treatments maybe she's sick for a
day she's back in the office the next
day very you know she's serving she had
an appointment an official appointment
at Arlington she served on the Arlington
committee and you know she's she's
taking calls and doing meetings from her
bedside you know and so she she kind of
kept focus on she didn't focus on what
her illness she focused on everything
else and it just got to the point at the
end where her body wouldn't allow her to
to keep going like that but it was it
was you know two weeks where she was
really we were like oh you're you're
sick but the rest of the time you would
have really never known you know people
look at pictures of my mom and I'm like
yeah that's just a couple weeks before
they did she died and they're like what
because you have you know the image in
your head if someone with dying of stage
four cancer Lee she just she didn't look
like that and what were you thinking
this whole time I was very pragmatic I
was like my mom's dying and eight months
I I did not my dad on the other side was
like I'm not listening to that like
there's there's miracles happen every
day we just got it you know stay the
course things we'll see if there's
trials you know they're trying all sorts
of different holistic diets and and I
was very much supportive of that let's
try everything and anything but I almost
felt so jaded at that point in in life a
little bit that I was like yeah I mean
we got we got eight months let's see
what these eight months look like
you say here grief is a savage and
shrewd beast that isn't easily tamed as
soon as I found a method of fending off
my grief that worked for me it caught on
and found a new mode of attack staying
goal-oriented and tough minded got me
only so far then the year my mother died
on Christmas night of 2012 it came to
find me in my home and so your mom dies
and you again this is all stuff that you
talk about in the book these big parties
that you guys have these big Christmas
parties and they kind of go they've gone
from generation to generation and your
grandparents had them than your parents
Adam and and so now it's your turn and
so you have this big party and you know
the the pandemonium or whatever of a
party and the planning and all that
stuff and then the party's over and
after the after the party you lay down
you know you're really tired from doing
all the work of getting it ready and
you're tired but here we go back to the
book but sleep didn't come something
much nastier arrived in its place I felt
like I received a direct punch to the
gut and my eyes immediately sprang open
I started hyperventilating I couldn't
breathe
pressure was quickly building inside my
chest and my mind was on fire with
anxiety it was the most terrifying panic
attack I had ever experienced Dave you
have to get me to a hospital I managed
to get out I think I'm dying I will
forever be grateful for what my husband
said next no you're not stop Ryan just
relax and go to bed and then you say you
might think I'm kidding but I'm serious
and I did think you were kidding and you
are serious my husband always knows what
to say to me when my emotions reach a
fever pitch if I had sensed even the
slightest bit of concern in his voice I
know the situation would have only
escalated at the time however as you may
imagine I did not appreciate it I
immediately set off into a flurry of
accusations that thankfully I could no
longer remember Dave the peaceful
warrior that he has remained unfazed
instead he continued to speak rationally
and firmly there's probably only a few
minutes but they felt like my last of
the intense feelings of anxiety when the
intense feelings of anxiety disappeared
and my breathing slowed into a natural
rhythm I had an internal come to Jesus
with myself clearly I was not okay I had
dealt with some minor anxiety before
initially when Travis was deployed and
then immediately after his death but
nothing like this
this was positively debilitating for
several for the next several months I
was a ghost of my former self the
identity had painstakingly built for
myself after Travis died had shattered
on December 24th 2012 I identified as a
tough capable resilient woman I was a
marathon runner I was a dedicated mom
and supportive wife I had taken over his
executive director of the Travis Manion
Foundation the organizer the
organization my mother had formed to
honor my brother I let a talented team
and people look to me for guidance and
leadership and I gave it to them but
December 25th was a different ballgame I
was gasping for air and cursing my
cursing out my exceedingly calm husband
I was smoking again I crying in the
shower and regularly feeling seized by
anxiety that I simply couldn't shake off
if this is what life is like going to be
if this is what life is going to be like
from now on I thought to myself one day
I'm done I can't live like this and then
you talk about communicating with some
of your friends commiserating with Amy
this is Brendan's Brendan's wife was
deeply helpful in putting me back on the
path to recovery two years earlier she
had lost her husband Brendan if there
was anyone with whom I felt I could be
completely vulnerable it was her one day
I called her overwhelmed and furious my
therapist diagnosed me with
post-traumatic stress disorder today I
shouted into the receiver can you
believe that shit I don't have PTSD and
then you go on and she says it's okay
Ryan she told me my therapist told me
the same thing at that point we both
chuckled and it dawned on me that there
was likely some truth to the diagnosis
naming my problem didn't do much for me
but sharing it with someone else did
during the following six months I
started to regain my confidence humor
and peace has slowly reclaimed myself
life slowed down I focused on my mental
health that did not mean I through
physical challenges out the window quite
the opposite I began to understand what
my dad meant when he told me to go for a
run when I wasn't feeling myself
exercise has a tremendous positive
effect on the mind I was using simple
exercise as a tool to help with my
mental state and you again you go into
some pretty good detail about this idea
of not just exercise but setting these
kind of little goals and doing things
that sort of give you an immediate
short-term gratification and you get
sort of on this treadmill of you're
looking for these short-term
gratification things to really propel
you for the next 10 minutes to whatever
next hour and you know whether it's a
run or whether it's a a goal or whether
it's some party or you're just you're
looking for you're looking for like
happiness yeah gratification temporary
joy but you realize it that's not giving
you the profound happiness that you're
looking for yeah
so you say this to break away from that
unforgiving pattern of searching for
unmatched joy you need to do one very
important thing you have to be honest
with yourself
no more self-deception for a long time I
have lied to myself about how happy and
fulfilled I felt frankly it was easier
that way I even lied about things that
made me feel happy and fulfilled if I
just stay busy I would think maybe the
story you tell yourself is a little
different if I just lose a few more
pounds if I just earn a few more
thousand dollars this year if I can just
get that guy to notice me then I'll be
happy then I'll be okay when we shed
those deceptive stories we tell
ourselves we create a space where we're
able to see what actually does make us
authentically happy I bet you'll find
you weren't totally off as I said we all
seek some the same things love
acceptance purpose we just look for them
in the wrong places when I talked with
Amy I knew that I had found them a sense
of community French
growth they were all right there laid
out in front of me and it was because I
took a moment of quiet away from the
activity and the chaos that I got to
experience and appreciate it in an
intentional and meaningful way intention
was the key that I'd been missing I was
so caught up in goals and milestones and
challenges and ambitions that I'd missed
the simple but profound element that
makes everything worthwhile and the fact
is I'm still hungry
I'm still ambitious I'm still a fighter
I like to push my body and do things I
may not quite be ready for and hell yes
I've still got goals and dreams but now
I also have something else I believe
that the single greatest key to
resilience is setting intentional goals
achieving a goal for the sake of
vainglory and sheer accomplishment will
bring satisfaction but that satisfaction
will prove to be short-lived achieving
goals that have deep meaning to us will
bring us far more happiness when we set
goals that have meaning outside of our
own selfish ends we discover it's not
about the destination it's about the
journey that's powerful and for me that
part right there at the end when we set
goals that have meaning outside of our
own selfish ends and that's the lesson
that when I when I hear Travis's story
it's like oh what made his life so
meaningful is that what he was doing was
not for himself everything he was doing
was so that he could be a leader so he
could be a warrior so he could protect
so he could defend yeah yeah it that you
know you talk about April 29 2007 is the
worst day of my life but if you try to
find out the worst time of my life
it would be after my mom passed away it
was one of those things where you know
you kind of do this
oh when I thought I was the when I
thought Travis being killed was the
woman being hit with the icicle fallen
off the garage like this is like let me
tell you about the craziest story I've
ever heard you know like how how could
my mom and my brother both not be here
and through that five years I was led by
my parents largely in terms of things I
was doing to honor my brother but it was
I don't say robotic but it was it was
these small little things it was like
okay run a marathon and it was like go
to this ceremony and five years out from
a loss there's still a lot of attention
that's brought to that loss in the loss
of a service member I mean you're going
to have you know you're going to have
the local schools that want to honor
them at Memorial Day you want the
families want to be brought in on
Veterans Day it's it's those things and
they kind of like they lead you through
the years and and I'll tell you what
they're meaningful and they and they
mean something and they're very much
appreciated but then after my mom was
killed or passed away I just felt lost I
was like oh my gosh like I don't I don't
know what you do from here and I I just
handled it the same way well okay you
know Travis Manion Foundation Board of
Directors three weeks after her death
holds a board meeting and they're like
you're up you know you're the president
oh well and when I joined my mom as
executive director I joined my mom as a
you know it was still a small
organization but she takes in five years
and turns it into one of the top leading
nonprofits for veterans in the country
and they're like okay Ryan go and I'm
like oh crap like I don't know what
do this I have no idea and I always tell
my husband he's gonna hate that I say
this I told him this was gonna be the
title of my next book he's like no it's
not but I said like I I did a little
like fake it till you make it
so I was like okay I'm the president and
and I know what I'm doing and you know
this is how it's gonna be and um and the
first thing I did I just started like
hiring really smart people I'm like okay
who are the smartest people I can find
and I'm gonna get them and they're gonna
be the team of leadership that's gonna
make sure that we drive this forward but
then there was also this tremendous
weight because here you had this
organization that was named after my
brother that had become like people at
this point like you say Travis Manion
and they know that name so there's a
heavy burden to make sure you uphold the
responsibility of what that name
represents and then on top of it you
uphold the responsibility of the woman
that created it that's no longer here so
I felt pressure like I had never felt
before
and I didn't take any steps to say okay
how intentional steps to say how do I
move forward doing this it was just
became the same rat race that I had been
doing for the five years prior it's like
okay gotta keep going and that felt
really tough to me I was like you know I
remember sitting there the day before my
mom's funeral and there was all these
people around much different scene than
the chaos around Travis's death I'm
sitting there and I'm like I need you to
do this this is my eulogy I want you to
go home go back and make these revisions
on the computer print it back like I was
running the show I'm like I'm in charge
I'm taking over I'm gonna make sure all
this is getting done and we do the most
beautiful tribute to this woman and
after that I kept going just with that
same like doo-doo-doo like grind every
single day whatever it may
be and then it was that Christmas party
where and my husband again you know he's
he he has some insight and he said I
don't think you throwing a Christmas
party this year for a hundred people is
smart like we are we've got so much
going on we are so incredibly
overwhelmed you're so busy like let's
just give it a rest I mean I think he
was even like dangling you know a trip
to the islands for Christmas in my face
and I'm like no way you know it's all
about the memories we have to have it
you know and the idea that the year
after my mom passes away we wouldn't
have this like that's just unheard of
like there's no way and so I continued
in that robot robot mode like this one I
got to do I have to execute this what
needs to be done and it was once I hit
that wall after it was done it was like
that was the mecca I'd hit it and
everything just came kind of crashing
down and you know that panic attack that
night it was I I've had anxiety a little
bit you know growing up in my teens like
you know what I should say what I
thought was anxiety this was literally I
thought I was dying I was like I'm I'm
I'm dying here on Christmas night and
and it was my husband being like and you
know he's like shut up you're not dying
I'm tired and it was hearing those words
like I'm tired I'm like alright well
clearly if I'm dying my husband's not
gonna tell me he's tired and to be quiet
you know and it brought me down but you
know after that it was waking up every
day that was one thing you know a panic
attack a year over something like and I
could understand that I got that it was
like well yeah you had a panic attack
because you've had such an adrenaline
rush for the last five months building
up to everything
been doing culminating with this event
that your mom used to host like I could
justify a panic it made sense like your
body was just having that letdown and it
went into an anxious response it was
that idea that I was waking up every day
and I woke up and upon eyes opening I
wasn't crying I was like shaking and I'm
like what is going on and I hid it for
awhile I didn't tell my husband I didn't
tell my friend like I told no one cuz
I'm just like so you know I really don't
want your husband to say shut up I'm
tired yeah yeah they're not good words
yeah in most cases yeah and I'm just
husband's beware yeah don't you know and
and to this eASIC you know Here I am
Who am I in the book the guy that tells
you to shut up when you're having a bad
time and not like now babe knows what I
mean um but it was that each and every
day you know and I got to the point
where I'm like mmm like I'm having
mental health issues right now like this
is not just a isolated event like
something's something's happening here
and to have me go sit on a couch with a
therapist was like for me that was that
was a big deal and a big deal because
you thought you're too you're too strong
for this you know it's just like not who
I was I mean I think when I opened up
the first time to my dad about this it
was my dad and my husband and we were in
the kitchen and I said hey I'm I'm
struggling I don't know what's going on
with me but I'm I'm not feeling right
I'm living in a perpetual state of
anxiety and I don't know how to get out
of it and you know at that time I I had
lorazepam it's like a low dosage xanax
that I had because I would take it when
I flew you know and oh here's something
just to cut the edge when you fly and
next thing you know like I'm taking
these every day and they're not even
doing anything
and
I'm like okay so I finally break down I
tell my dad and tell my dad and Dave and
my dad's like first response is well I
mean I haven't seen you working out in a
while Ryan so I mean that and that's how
I was raised and he was like you know I
mean you got to go out and run and I'm
like and and I knew that was going to be
the response and so for a while I was
like well I'm not gonna say anything but
from there it was you know and in my
dad's defense you know I think after he
he said that I broke down in tears I'm
like it's not good you know and he was
like oh crap something serious is going
on here and so you know we I got into
therapy and in therapy helps yeah so
this is something that I've realized so
I used to not really understand what
therapy was or what a psychologist did
or any of that yeah and to me it just
seemed like voodoo whatever kind of
things right and it wasn't until a
friend of mine
Jordan Peterson who's a who's a
psychologist came on here and he was he
explained to me like two k2 things that
he solved for people and that's when I
realized and I coined a term of my own
called either mind mechanic or like
brain mechanic because when your car
when your car isn't running right you
don't just keep driving it you go oh
this is running right I'm gonna take it
to my mechanic and the mechanic actually
everyday sees different cars with
different problems and knows how to fix
them so a psychologist or a therapist
they deal with people that have been
through all these different things and
they have little solutions form to tell
you two things to do to to to get your
mind in the right space so you can carry
on that's what they're doing they're not
doing any voodoo voodoo they're just
doing some mind mechanic adjustments
yeah and you can't imagine how I know
for me I think my first therapy session
I went in and she's asking me questions
and and you know it's like I'm having a
conversation with a friend and then she
co K times up I'm like well when are we
gonna start therapy she's like I was
there
and I'm like oh did she give you did she
give you like techniques totally yeah
can you give me example of just one so
you know there's like the breathing
techniques of course like for me a lot
of it was like the breathing because I
would get to like these peaked peak
feelings of anxiety where you know it
was like fight-or-flight and it was like
breathing exercises to help get me back
down so she says okay when you start
feeling like that here's what you're
gonna do yeah tell me what would you do
like you know it was you know you I
think one of them was like you're gonna
take a deep breath in you're gonna hold
it for three seconds and then you're
gonna let it out for ten seconds while
holding your diaphragm so you can
actually like feel the breast coming out
I developed my own techniques to like I
have to this day I've developed my own
techniques to help when I'm feeling
anxious give me example for me oh
they're so girly but yeah my my examples
I'm not saying I'm gonna use it so one
of my examples is most of the time and I
actually don't most time I keep my my
nails polished okay and I can get it oh
and I'll like peel the nail polish off
if I'm feeling super anxious but what it
is more than that
wait so that's a sign that you're
getting anxious no no that's like if I'm
super anxious or if you're super anxious
you start picking at your fingernails
yeah
taking the nail polish off okay so put
the nail polish on because I don't want
to pick the skin off my finger so that's
a that's a technique is to that's my
technique it's not it okay but it's it's
something that calms you somehow yeah
you know what it is though I'll say it's
not so much the peeling the nail polish
off here
it's finding something that you have to
concentrate on so once I pick a piece of
nail polish off my finger I'm not gonna
let my hands look like that so I have to
get every last piece of nail polish off
without nail polish remover with my with
my fingers and that takes time and
effort and I just become focused on that
and so that it's like that's
thing can kind of bring you into for me
it brings me into a place of like I'm
concentrating on this so one thing that
I realize that I do uh-huh
is when when you're in the military when
you talk on the radio you don't want to
sound like you're panicking and right
and so like if I was gonna key that
radio and be like no matter what was
going on it
you know we're whether I'm just exerting
physical energy or there's chaos going
on it always be like oh I'm gonna talk
on the radio and I just put on the calm
voice you know and I think that's when
you when you say hey we need 14 more
guys to come over to this building now
and when everyone hears you and you hear
yourself you're like okay things aren't
that bad we're good so I was for me
we're trying to keep my voice in check
and I think that leads to a sense of
calmness even know not just outwardly
but inwardly as well yeah I never really
realized that it's all until I started
having conversations with people about
this very thing because people say well
how did you remain calm and I would
think about it I'll just stay calm and
then I thought well what's it well let's
think about it what actually and the
other thing is I would tell guys you
know that I was training I'd be like hey
man don't you know I'd hear a guy on the
radio really ignore guys over here now
during a training operation and I'd say
bro you need to calm down don't sound
like down ready freaking everyone else
yeah and and they're freaking out yeah
and so when I go bro don't talk like
that say it again say calm and they'd be
like hey we need six more guys moving
forward and you could see them visibly
I'd watch them they would get calmer
yeah because you have to get control so
those are the kind of things that the
mind mechanic will give you these tools
totally and and you know but for me it
was it was less about staying calm it
was about like I was afraid of that
crescendo where literally it's that
fight-or-flight and you don't want to go
off that edge and so it was like when I
get to that point what what do I do
because I don't know if you've ever had
an actual panic attack or not you feel
like you're dying it is the craziest
feeling in the world the thing that
makes me really which must make this
hard right is if you
like let's say you're starting to have a
panic attack yeah isn't it like a
snowball because you're like on that one
oh my god it's coming oh my god it's
gonna be it's gonna be a bad one
so it actually it's a it it's like self
it propels itself to make myself work
whoa you know I so I was saying I used
to take like lorazepam when I flew you
know and it was just like hey it was
like my fear of you know flying right I
fly so much now I'm over it but people
we say we're were you scared of the
plane crashing and I was like no I was
scared of getting too scared on the
plane you know like I don't want to be
on the plane and start getting scared so
I'm gonna yeah I mean it's like though
your your head does crazy things you
know but yeah I worked through that and
you know I was very intentional about
even when I felt like okay I'm coming
out of this I'm feeling better
it wasn't like I'm gonna stop I was like
I okay I gotta keep going and I'm gonna
keep going until she tells me it's you
you know how long did that take it was
about six months of like intensive
therapy where I'm talking like how many
times a week two to three times a week
and exercise so after you so exercise
becomes again a big part of it but it's
not exercise where I'm gonna run a
marathon or I'm gonna it was like I'm
gonna go out for a run every day every
other day because it's what my mind
needs not necessarily what my body needs
I was talking to my friend Joe Rogan on
his podcast Yeah right after Chris
Cornell killed himself he like killed
himself that day or the day before and
so we started this podcast and look I
mean obviously I'm no psychologist and
we were just talking we weren't trying
to give out advice but you know both of
us was like you know got to get some
exercise and a million people said you
have no idea what you're talking about
like I know I'm just saying that you
know it feels good to work out but then
what was interesting was a
my other friend Tim Ferriss who actually
went through like a suicidal episode in
his life and he's and and he's like no
you have to like get outside and
exercise even though Hank you feel
better I don't subscribe to anybody that
thinks that your physical health is not
100% tied to your mental health like you
know I used to think my dad was
incredibly insensitive when I would try
to talk to him about like you know
ailments of the mind and he would tie it
all back to like you know well if you
ran or but you know what like he was
right yeah he was right and is it all
that is it like yeah hey I'm suffering
from depression
go run no but it is it is 100% a
component my husband runs every single
day every day he runs and he's he's
people like oh you're gonna run the
marathon he's like I'll never run a
marathon again he's like I run to live
my life like it's all it's all foreign
mate it's all maintenance for him it's
just about like in order for me to be
clear-headed to be a good husband and to
be a good father and to be good at my
job I have to run every day so what's
cool about this you know for folks that
are listening right now that are running
into whatever difficulties are going
through like hey cool the initial
whatever the initial prescription is
hanging outside yeah and then like you
said if it goes beyond that then what do
we need well then you need to go and see
a brain mechanic yeah which is what you
said your dad hey Dad
it's not by running yeah right which I
probably had some conversations with
like that about with my kids you know
where you know my daughter's you go say
like I just don't feel like doing
anything right now I was like well that
means you need to do something right
yeah and I'm sure it's some time at some
points are going to God my dad's an
idiot but I want to say that you just
said that your dad witching kind of
supports my position your dad
he was right so yes right get some
exercise but then if it goes beyond that
and you still feel the the issues then
you've got to get some some help yeah
for sure a couple more things to wrap
this up along the road to intention I
came across countless bunts and bumps
and pitfalls but I also learned some a
few valuable truths first don't use a
jackhammer when a chisel will do when I
saw a problem in front of me I went at
it with a jackhammer I was convinced
that if I applied enough force to it I
could make it go away but some problems
even big ones need only a well deployed
chisel in tension is the chisel I was
introduced to in tension when my mom
received her eight-month prognosis
Travis's young life had been ripped from
mine violently and quickly but in the
case of my mom I was given the
opportunity to say my goodbyes I asked
her questions about her life and wrote
down her responses we spent every day
together and she held my girls every
chance she got after she died all that
disappeared I believed for time that I
had been robbed I was heartbroken and
right back where I had started but then
I rely on intentionality
I was crudely reminded of how short
sweet and precious our lives are I know
the cost of not having the opportunity
to say what or do what matters most and
I refuse to squander the blessings that
I have been given I choose to live life
with in tension your next piece of
advice second it's not either/or it's
both and let me be clear intention is
not rep meant to replace goals and
ambitions it's meant to color them
committing to vigorous feats physical
mental or otherwise is often a good in
its own right maybe you want to pass
those boards or crushed that personal
best time or compete for that promotion
these are all good things
these names are fueled by discipline and
focus but they are nourished
by intention difficult to attain goals
and accomplishments are what keep our
heart rates up and our blood pumping
they give us life but intention is what
gives our lives meaning it's what makes
life worth living then this is your last
piece of advice that on me to cover from
the book it says failure is a bruise not
a tattoo before Travis died I never
bothered to think much about failure
that's not because I was wildly
successful at everything I tried my hand
at believe me I failed a plenty of
things rather was because I didn't care
enough about anything to give it much
effort I was sometimes apathetic
Travis was ambitious Travis was the
ambitious goal oriented one I was just
coasting through life after he died and
then my mom died I had a major wake-up
call now I feel I feel compelled to take
advantage of the time I have left on
this earth to lead a life they both can
be proud of
and I think that's a a good place to
stop on my readings from this book to
lead a life that they can be proud of
because that message right there is just
as a powerful message and it's one that
I know that I think about every single
day every single day I think about that
and mind you we've only covered like a
third of this book right here mm-hmm
right there are stories and lessons from
Heather and from Amy and like I said
hopefully I can have them on and if I
can go through their lessons learned and
their experiences I look forward to
doing that
but in the meantime for folks out there
get this book and and what's what's
awesome is those stories in this book
the stories the book comes to an end and
we're gonna end this but the but the
story doesn't end there because Travis
and Brendon and Robert are still having
a huge impact and we've been talking
about this the the foundation that your
mom started the Travis Manion foundation
in which you are now the president of
the president of that yes and Amy's one
of the vice presidents Amy's vice
president and then Heather is uh manager
program manager here in San Diego the
West Region yeah that's right so I mean
the lessons that you're putting on this
is all in this book are awesome tell us
a little bit before we before we stop
tell us a little bit about the Travis
Manion foundation first of all like what
what's the mission what's the goal I
mean really at the Travis Manion
foundation we are we're creating a
community and we want to make sure that
we are giving returning veterans and
families of the Fallen the opportunity
to continue to serve and more
importantly to be able to empower them
post military life I think you know when
you look at today 55% of men and women
who are taking off the uniform when you
ask them what their greatest challenges
it's that that loss of purpose you know
they don't have that sense of purpose in
their life anymore and we have no
shortage of ways at TMF to give you
purpose again and one of our biggest
drivers and a lot of it is you know it
speaks to I talk about Travis as a young
kid and I say like you know there was
something different about him but it
didn't come without having incredible
Mentors
you know my uncle Chris my dad some of
his teachers growing up the the coaches
Joe Sherrod at the wrestling at the
Naval Academy his wrestling coach like
these were the the mentors that helped
frame him into who he became and so we
know the importance of that and we know
the opportunity have we have with a
group of men and women who basically
were taught leadership and so it's like
okay so let's take this group of men and
women who were taught to lead and serve
and just say thanks for your service no
how about like okay you're back here
you're out well can you teach these kids
how to leave in lead and surf so we
trained veterans to go out and mentor
youth and they're out across the country
taking them through both physical and
experiential learning challenges to
build their own service and leadership
and not in a way to indoctrinate the
next generation to all join the military
but in a way to say hey listen as men
and women like you and Travis and
Brendan and Rob like they were called to
serve this country in military but as
Americans each and every one of us is
called to serve like we have a
responsibility to do that and if we're
not passing that down to the next
generation
then we're failing and so that's that's
kind of our Drive at the foundation so
we're we just want to create a community
that wants to pass that
and we've got eight offices across the
country we've got a membership base of
about a hundred and twenty thousand
people and you know we we we call
ourselves the Spartans like and we're
largely made up of civilians believe it
or not but these are people that feel
that sense of pride for men and women
like you you know and they want to be
able to eat that up and be a part of it
and and be servant leaders right in
their own backyards and our our
organization does not exist if we don't
have veterans leading the charge and
gold star families like they run our
programs so we're not a veteran service
organization in the way where we're
saying this is what we offer to you
we're a veteran service organization
that says hey we really want to do good
stuff in the communities so we need you
guys to help us out ya know it's an
awesome program that that I you guys
made a video we did it that I mean I
went to LA but but what's awesome is
they're just they're getting to kids you
know and the same idea that I had yeah
Chazz which is hey there's a bunch of
kids in the world and what they need is
to learn about life and learn about the
word that you guys use which I will use
as well because it's the right words
character yeah and and how do you teach
these young kids character well that's
we know I've written a bunch of kids
books that that try to teach kids about
character and the values that will the
values that will give them a better life
right that will give them a better life
and will give everyone around them a
better life as well so that's awesome
the other thing that's awesome is what
you just said you know me you know many
times a day I get a message from someone
that says hey 52 years old and I never
served and I feel like I regret it and I
wish I could have what should I do
it's like this is what you do yeah this
is what you do you you you help propel
the message in the and the messages of
character back to the veterans from the
veterans back to the youth that's what
you do you there's so many different
ways to serve you don't have to put on a
uniform to serve there's so many
different ways to serve and what you
guys are doing is offering offering
people the opportunity to find other
ways to serve that are just as impactful
I'll tell you right now you go out there
and you help three kids
get on the right path in their life that
is the biggest service you can make to
the country that's it that's it go do
that that has such a massive impact and
you guys are enabling that you guys are
at so if people want to if people want
to get on board yeah we go to Travis
Manion org Travis Manion org yep you can
join the mission right there we have it
and I mean it walks you through
everything like this is everything we do
what do you want to be a part of you
know and yeah join the mission and learn
more you're a social media because echo
is really into social media so it's on
Twitter it's TM foundation correct on
Instagram which echo calls the Graham
the Graham yeah it's Travis Manion
foundation on Facebook it's Travis
Manion foundation and you guys have a
YouTube channel as well we do we've got
great videos there's a couple of you up
there actually is there more than one
yeah well they broke down some of your
outtakes and just did like it's like a
minute long like wait is it bloopers
it's not bloopers it's like thoughts
from Jocko like no it was cool I was
gonna say I know how many bloopers cuz
they had a big chunk of time like hours
and hours yeah and I was like how long
it's gonna take you like well we got
five hours set aside and I was like okay
that's a long video yeah but it didn't
take that long well it was funny cuz I
was with Pat Chapman who was the one
that that filmed you he was the producer
of the the piece and he's a good friend
of mine he lives in LA and he said I
said oh I'm doing Jacko's podcast on
Friday and he said oh my gosh I have to
tell you he said you know I got in the
car with like I guess like the grips or
whatever and he said yeah you know we're
doing we're doing a shoot today this
guy's name is Jacque and they were like
are you kidding me
and he's like at least good I always
think they weren't in the military so I
didn't he's a guy thought it was really
like heavily focused on the military
he's like these are like my key grips
and they were like oh my god Jaakko they
were thrilled that's Allison yeah yeah
it's really interesting the the
demographics of people that listen to
podcast it's everyone yeah it's really
it's really cool and and you know like
they find well this is a great
opportunity for them to find a way to
serve because everyone feels that if you
let somewhere in their system yeah if
you go through your life looking out for
yourself without helping other people
you look up one day and you'll say I
want to help other people yeah that's
just that's just the way it is yeah so
those are the ways to help to join the
mission joint like the way you said that
yeah I kind of got I got it better
that's good psychology some things I
hear that I'm like what it's not real
easy when it comes to things like that
you start throwing those words around
and all of a sudden I'm breaking out the
knives getting ready to go to battle
yeah say that like new mission or
whatever I use that too you know yeah
very effective yeah well that's
something that I say all the time to
vets like when you get done with your
military service you need a new mission
totally and the people that don't get a
new mission they wander around and not
knowing what to do so here's a good way
whether your civilian whether your
military to get on board thanks for
lunch cute the mission you got anything
else I mean obviously gonna encourage
everyone to go get the book yes
get the book knock the knock at the door
it's out right now you if you order this
right now you'll get a first edition
which so I'm really in the first
editions yeah yeah you gotta get the
first two dish so if you guys want first
a dish of knock on the door and then
you'll be able to fuck people always say
how come you don't tell us what books
you're gonna do on the podcast it's cuz
I don't know what books I'm gonna do on
the podcast until like a couple days
before I do it yeah but with this one
since I'll have hopefully Heather and
Amy on at some point you'll be able to
have the book in your possession and
have already read it oh yeah take
through three parts yeah so knock at the
door and
you can you can follow me our Mannion at
you know on Facebook and Instagram and
Twitter just to you know because I put
up foundations not putting up a terrible
amount about the book okay but you know
I'm pushing out everything where we're
going to be okay so you're doing events
and stuff for the book yeah promoting
the book getting the book out there
that's right spread the message signings
you know so yeah all that sort of stir
it yeah speaking of a mission yes you're
on a mission I want a mission well you
know thank you so much for coming I mean
it's it's awesome and I know we have
some mutual friends you know
that's which is cool yeah and Jamie who
works national on front her husband
Flynn who was awesome friends he was
awesome friends with Brendan in the head
as a matter of fact they have a son
named Brendan yeah I mean you know Jamie
and Flynn a lot of the stories that are
in the book a lot of stories that aren't
in the book you know they were a part of
them who they were they were there you
know I mean especially in in a me
section you know Flynn and Jamie were a
really integral part of at that time
yeah well thank you for the three you
for writing this book for sharing the
challenges that you've gone through the
triumphs the it's this I know like I
said that the stories in this book are
gonna help they're gonna help people
that are struggling when they're knock
at the door whatever that knock at the
door is when it comes their way
this book will will help them get
through it and even more important than
that thank you for the service and
sacrifice of your family that you guys
have made it's obviously something that
I will never forget and nor will our
great nation ever forget that
and thanks for what you're doing with
the Travis Manion foundation to keep his
legacy and his spirit and his character
alive in order to make the world a
better place which
you are doing thank you well thanks for
continuing to have the platform to share
these stories you know it's important so
we appreciate it it's an honor to be
able to do it thank you for coming on
Thanks
and with that Ryan Mannion has left the
building
awesome conversation and some good
advice yeah actual pragmatic advice on
what to do how to help yourself
how to help yourself do those moments a
part of it was part of it was goals
right goals with intention you keep
yourself on the path going out for runs
I thought that was interesting because
every time how she would say how Tom or
her dad and I would say yeah just go for
a run or whatever thing we kind of say
that about you just to a lot of times go
change and it's true it's sure here's
the thing for I'm not gonna just I mean
we just talked about it where it's true
but it's not like yeah yeah there's that
antidote you know it is for some stuff
you know I wish I would have thought of
this it is a little bit more of an
antidote than running in my opinion I
think so too but it's like one it's like
a couple measures of effectiveness
because there's a mental aspect to it
that completely covers all the mental
aspects of running and then gives
additional bonuses yeah and then I want
to Majan obviously I'm not an expert but
I would imagine that it would this
varies from person to person you know
some people they'll maybe go lift
weights I remember when I was young when
I'd be mad at something and keep in mind
I'm on Kauai mad at something so
whatever very very mild madness sessions
oh I would want to go work out like
going to work out and getting under the
bench like that would help that would be
very therapeutic
Ronnie Sorella and treadmill - mm-hmm
back not
you know before not anymore but I
surrounded in trouble too same thing
very therapeutic
I thought the lifting was more
therapeutic and then jiu-jitsu is like
magnitudes top of the therapeutic
pyramid in terms of physical activity by
far - like by far look at more than one
level like two levels so you're
definitely recommending jiu-jitsu as
well many things you just say yes for
many reasons fan we've talked about and
we're gonna continue to talk about
jiu-jitsu bottles when you do Jiu Jitsu
you will need a uniform you will Aggie
if you're doing gay which we do
recommend as always well Geary are you
gonna get you're gonna I have not been
getting the question what we should I
get anymore I have not we're getting out
there the word is getting out and we're
gonna continue to put it out origin geez
get one of our keys and buy our geese I
mean us all of us the group you know cuz
because we are part of this thing oh
yeah
part of this gang and we're all using
we're all supporting we're all on board
with the program origin well made in
America yeah materials because sometimes
people they say made in America I took
assembled in America yeah they really
mean yeah we're you know made in America
oh yeah sewn and manufactured grown oh
it to the raw materials all American
without compromise one of these you can
get geese you can get rash guards you
can get t-shirts and you can get jeans
that's right American general jeans made
in America and but boots oh that's right
did you get yours yet yes sir how you
doing I feel very good what are you
wearing boots though I don't wear boots
so all of a sudden you just have boots
when you win they're gonna where they
get I don't know but here's the
interesting thing and this goes we need
a first order yeah but like anything you
know when you're excited about it right
I forgot that in the mainland you guys
call them flip-flops yeah yeah yeah
you know like when you get an exciting
new piece of apparel you more you
actively look for opportunities to wear
them so you know these boots they're
gonna get worn official I put them on of
course but I don't know actually we're
in the field whatever that means in my
case but what's cool about boots is
there they're not for wearing to the
grocery store I mean you can but they're
they're legit awesome work boots made in
Farmington Maine aesthetically pleasing
I don't like your easy word pleasing but
you like the way they look yeah they
have legitimate aesthetics to them more
heavy their functionality is good yes
and they're not overboard
aesthetically which would give them
disapproved by me in fact as far as I'm
concerned they are the perfect boot yeah
actually when you think about it they
are a boot if you looked in the
dictionary boot you'd see a pair of
origin boots like that's what you expect
a pair of boots to look like yes why
because that's how boots have been honed
over centuries to get to a point where
you go okay this is what a boot is yeah
the most the most boot a boot can be is
a boot from origin man so yeah you can
get that also what supplements oh yeah
no just gonna say when you're on the
path supplements they help they
supplement the path discourse yeah what
a percent but yeah so it look I slipped
off the train of well not the mole but V
here right on the oh man all day all day
but I had like any crap my wife made me
an incredible dinner yesterday
flank steak just all just good to go
I'm a nice little Caesar salad these are
like my two things but the flank steak
was just perfect and I got done with it
and I was like yeah that was so good and
I was like but I want some something so
I just got a little I got a little scoop
and a half hitter
that's the whole deal I guess so like a
deal and a half one scoop or is to know
on one scoop is it that you can have a
one scoop hood I mean you can have a two
scoop hitter for sure oh yeah that's not
really it's a little bit more what is
the 131 scoop ones right yeah yeah
so mulk what it is is it's additional
protein but you're not gonna know what
you're gonna think is you just gotten to
the additional dessert so the joint
warfare and krill oil this is important
I slipped off krill oil here's the thing
right I didn't like forget I ran out I
forgot to get more before I ran out of
one of those situations again so and
then it's weird how this is what Jade
called it it's a hyper typing induced
tennis elbow okay I can that makes sense
right being on the computer whatever and
I got tennis elbow over here Wow
right when I read stuff it was like four
ish days after I got off the krill oil
still joint warfare I'm still into that
you know elbow cured by the way oh
but yeah that's that's the situation I
feel bad people will ask me which one a
or b you know should I be on during
warfare krill oil which one should it
being and I'm like I hate answering that
question because as far as I'm concerned
it's both it's like peanut butter and
jelly right you're not just gonna go
peanut butter you're not just gonna go
tell your peanut butter I go joint
warfare and super krill yeah
yes and with it and I'm on like a
program where it's like lifting like
hard and this face I'm a little bit more
old school now like I'm not as young as
me that's our technique great but oh
your own not just old school but
actually all you know so the yes so this
it's saying a lot when I don't have the
elbow thing anymore and that was a
common thing when I was lifting with no
joints supplements before you did your
whole thing mmm oh it was a big I just
endured just endured every once in a
while take like ibuprofen or something
like that because that
that not good for ya but otherwise I
just want them up more now no fact
they're gone aside from my my tennis
elbow
but anyway keeping elbow type indecent
yeah I was not playing tennis
unfortunately nonetheless yes so yes
joint warefare krill oil Molk
disciplined hmm so we got that we got
the Jocko Palmer flavor which is a 50%
iced tea 50% lemonade flavor mm-hmm it's
the greatest thing ever
is that how good oh yeah it's out its
out I said I said as soon I told I don't
belittle I'm like as soon cuz I had
tried the you know we went through all
the trials to get the right taste when
we got the right taste and I was like
run this make it and I said as soon as
the factory gets done making it Federal
Express it to my house because it's
taste so good
better than Tropic Thunder you think all
right like it's my opinion is is yes
right now right now the the powdered
discipline in Jaco Palmer flavor is my
favorite flavor at this time I'm not
saying I won't occasionally do a little
lemon lime hitter or a tropic thunder
and don't forget that we also have the
cans all right one go and that's wasn't
say like the cans to me hey I like lemon
lime fine but the tropic thunder is like
there's no way I would ever under any
circumstances grab the lemon lime one
the tropic thunders right there's no way
well I mean you know I think that might
be from your upbringing it's possible oh
yeah it's very tropical yeah I used to
be like over there yeah and and then you
got chocolate white tea as well
Organic white sort of fun it's like only
organic consumable that is guaranteed to
give you an 8,000 pound deadlift so you
know after we prove by the way
double-blind also if you or when you get
your copy of the knock at the door by
Ryan Mannion Heather Kelly and Amy
Looney Heffernan
don't worry Zack God I got you you know
have to go searching even though I'm
sure that'd be easy to find regardless
but put it on jockle podcast calm under
the book section and here's another good
way to support the podcast if you want
to click there click through there it'll
take you to Amazon on that Amazon
landing to where it lands just save that
to your favorites if you ever if you've
done this before August 1st I'm sorry we
got to do it again for various reasons
that we're not going to go into but
nonetheless if you do that then shopping
dude amazon shopping through that link
that's a good way to support this
podcast very good way if you want but
yeah so yeah it'll be on there and yeah
get it there so you can not only support
yourself but you know get to get the
whole book so you can get all the
details and whatnot also Chuck was a
store to call Jaco store anyway that's
where you can you see the guy that wrote
on Twitter
his wife said what do you want for your
birthday
and he said Jaco has a store it's called
jaw closed or boom there you go yes
that's all she needed to know yeah cuz
everything that you can get there he's
down with yeah he's like just order
something from there you know you can
order a rash guard you can order a
t-shirt you can order a trucker's hat I
guess if you are feeling like maybe you
don't feel as cool as you want to be you
can order a flex fit hat
oh yeah or a lightweight hoodie yeah you
know ready admit it when you see people
wearing the lightweight hoodie it's good
you're kind of getting one over right
not one over my labor and I'll say
probably not right now a little bit a
little bit functional functional 8ly
functional and it slightly aesthetic I
dig it no less yeah if you want to
represent while you're on the path
jacques cousteau a connoisseur you get
to stuff you can also subscribe to this
podcast which is a good idea if you
haven't yet which echo doesn't think you
have maybe that's because echo is the
type of person that is listening to
something for years and doesn't hit
subscribe and so he doesn't think you
will
you can be like echo and hit subscribe
now or maybe if you're like me you
already hit subscribe so you know what's
interesting about that this is obviously
not the first time you said that
echo doesn't think that you subscribe
technically that's not true that's not
how it went down I was not aware so if
you probably just missed remembered it
and then again I could be wrong right
now too and maybe I missed didn't
remember quickly but what it was was I
was saying you don't have to tell people
to subscribe because they're even going
to subscribe if they want to or not you
don't be like hey subscribe no my gosh I
totally forgot to subscribe it's kind of
like an obvious thing that was my
contention anyway so that's more
accurate okay but additionally today you
put a lot of things on me didn't what do
you say that I called it the gram that
whole line of a gram whatever we're
saying you saying I'm not taking
ownership of things oh yeah that's true
too yeah this is interesting
yeah but I'm just I'm actually it's
nothing to take ownership I'm not
blaming you for calling at the gram I'm
just stating that you call it the grant
even though I don't it's almost time for
me to read some reviews mm-hmm aloud
again done that before but yeah so leave
some reviews if you leave a review
that's shockingly creative you know and
good you know thank you then you know
maybe I'll just retweet it or something
or read it and I also want to do the I
also want to read YouTube comments out
loud yeah we should do like what there's
a show like I thought and I forget if
there's a bunch of shows I know Brian or
someone yeah mean tweets yeah yeah you
should do that with the with the and not
necessarily mean ones cuz no one's clear
people can be lame well yeah I'm not
gonna be like it this guy's yeah you
know look here's this little cry during
mean tweets or I've seen some people
crying when they're reading mean tweets
like really crying yeah yeah yeah like
legitimately like like you know like to
show the power of internet bullying or
whatever okay so you're not gonna get
there yeah but I would I would wonder is
obviously yeah you're not gonna start
crying but if you say yeah I'm gonna
read it then people will be like oh let
me make a mean one and then sometimes if
someone's intention hey if you're if
you're gonna try and beat mean to me
through comments have a negative impact
on me
I hate to break the news to you you're
not executing well cuz I don't care yeah
actually you want to write something
cool and you want me to see it and be
like awesome
yeah then that didn't you're being
effective yes no well but this though
was what you're saying well it like if
we if you if we decide for you to read
mean comments people someone might be
motivated to be oh let me see if I can
get a zinger in there and then it's just
sort of whack because for a mean comment
to be funny it has to be funny first
then mean so here's the here's that
really here's the really kind of just
thing that shots that idea down to read
a mean like a truly mean comment it's
not even it's not funny you're you know
what I mean
if you make a funny comment right like
the person that got a picture of me and
it says feeling cute might like hey man
that's funny yeah full credit to that
one yeah cuz it's a boy that was even
like Oh Charles that pic pictured that
oh yeah Michael Charles posted that but
yes so that picture was taken about
three seconds before because this
photographer this is a legit
photographer was taking pictures of me
they're like photoshoot yeah you were
modeling yeah no they were taking
pictures of me Oh
but anyways they're like I'm like just
they're like we'll just walk around and
act natural and so I'm like walking
around and I'm like looking I'm looking
in the in this in this pic right where
that fence is and then I look at them
and then and then they're like taking a
much pictures and then they started
giving me direction they're like they're
like we can you look over there and look
at us real quick give me ad
and I was like no I'm not doing that
this is this is not me and I'm not doing
it but that picture was the one picture
that they got right before they started
give me directions ni and I told them
negative not happening
but even that picture looks lame hey man
that's debatable you know maybe you know
it looked cute might delete it later hey
bottom line leave some reviews you know
we have fun with them
we appreciate cool reviews so that'd be
awesome and don't forget about the
warrior kid podcast mm-hmm which I know
I owe more of oh this is starting to
sound really bad yeah yeah I guess maybe
we should release that one in the bank
sure okay um yeah so or your kid podcast
and don't forget about the warrior kids
soap from Irish Oaks ranch calm we're
young Aidan is making soap so that you
and we all also youtube channel we have
a youtube channel video version of this
podcast and excerpts a lot of excerpts
on there a little you know chopped up
here's the thing about YouTube's is what
I heard when I learned people now people
now are going to YouTube more for a
little bit longer videos than before
some of the trailers like oh yeah minute
and a half it's like you got to keep
their attention on the internet and
stuff that was kind of the thing right
so apparently the new emergent status is
the people we like the longer form stuff
we're beginning to let your learner's
from catching off of that over there yes
isn't this like we've been making
three-hour podcast for years but yes but
remember yes
well no no okay three our pockets that's
audio right we're talking audio
long-form okay do you have we have a
five hour and 25-minute long podcast
with sean Parnell yes but as far as the
trend goes people like it generally
speaking more know so people outside of
the people that listen to this podcast
are starting to like okay just yeah in
general and so what's your probably
details some of the excerpts are kind of
long like five minutes eight minutes oh
right right so the times that I was
telling you can you please make an
excerpt that's not 27 minutes long
you're saying I was wrong well I
not to split hairs I'm not saying you
were wrong then I'm saying that no
longer applies as far as like what you
might want nonetheless there's some
excerpts on there well for YouTube
channel if you want something shorter
than that you can go to psychological
warfare which is available on iTunes and
all mp3 platforms which is me giving
some short maybe minute minute and a
half maybe two minutes at the longest
audio advice of how to stay on the path
if and it's not just advice it's actual
mechanical tool that will keep you on
the path very very effective too
it's like you're you could go to a
therapist to try and get you to not eat
a doughnut or you could just press play
you know boom and then leave it down
right here the sugar-coated lies
flipside canvas if you need some visual
representation of the path you go to
flipside canvas dot-com owned by my
brother Dakota Meyer you can get
discipline equals freedom you can get
good you can get whatever you want
actually let Dakota know what you think
would be cool and he'll make it
flipside canvas calm Dakota might have
it's a helicopter
yes he does did you say that you did
right in that are you you're not that
yeah okay yeah I was gonna make a video
of like myself or you mm-hmm and be like
hey like Dakota I see Dakota Myers
helicopter and it's like so cool so we
decided to get our own mm-hmm and then
we'd get it and then we do they like or
you get in there and you'd take off and
then you'd like crash it or something or
before you get any catches on fire or
something you know kind of like you want
to copy people but you're you know you
failed at it or something so are we
having a meeting right now about
creative ideas I wanted to say it out
loud just to see your reaction to see
where I need to spin this idea you know
I want you spend that idea right along
with the helicopter
that also we got some books obviously
the book of the knock at the door right
here Ryan Mannion Heather Kelly
Amy Luna Heffernan and get the book
comes out November 5th it's a but order
right now it'll ship and you'll get it
early also leadership strategy and
tactics Field Manual just got approval
from the Department of the Defense
Department of Defense which took a long
time but they just gave me approval to
publish it made it through the
declassification process so we're good
to go
pre-order that now it will be out in
January and believe me when I tell you
you want that first a dish and we got
the warrior kid books there's three of
them where there's a will marks mission
and their first one way the warrior kid
get those don't forget about Mikey and
the dragons for every kid that you know
between the ages of 0 and 100 get a
Mikey and the Dragons young people have
told me they cried when they read the
letter yes or no I don't know how many
but that doesn't surprise me because
remember I think I don't do this I think
I told you this yeah when I played the
video that part for some reason what are
you you're like do my son and it you
know and especially if you have kids
you're like oh man you know you're
sending your kid off into the crazy
world you know kind of on his own it's
like man it's kind of like yeah I dig it
man I understand so get that book for
everybody that you know don't forget it
as a discipline equals freedom Field
Manual if you want to know my personal
operating system for mental and physical
health that's it the discipline equals
freedom with Field Manual the audio
version is available as an mp3 wherever
get your mp3s and also we have extreme
ownership and the dichotomy leadership
which I wrote with my brother life
babban which you can take the lessons
that we learned in combat and apply them
to your business your family and your
life
Ashlin front that's my leadership
consultancy and what we do is solve
problems through leadership no matter
what problems you have in an
organization the problems guaranteed our
leadership problems go to a salon front
comm for details and if you want to get
someone from a salon front to come and
speak to your organization don't go
through a speaker's agency just go to a
salon front comm that's what you do
otherwise there's a middleman and the
middleman will make things annoying so
just go to a salon front comm we have EF
online where you can you can receive
leadership training without us actually
being there we had a car I was working
with a company when I got done talking
with his executives he came up to me and
said I want you to talk to and teach and
train every employee habit this company
I said cool how many employees do you
have
167,000 I think was the number there was
one that was 87,000 the biggest one was
106 m anyways global company and I said
okay let me get back to you on that so
anyways how do you do that obviously we
can't clone our instructors and echelon
front but we can put them on interactive
high-speed online leadership training
that's what EF online.com is so check
that out if you do want to come and see
us live go to extreme ownership comm to
find out when we do our leadership
training event which is called the
muster the next one is in December 4th
and 5th in Sydney Australia we will not
be going back to Sydney Australia for a
long long long long time we're not going
to Brisbane we're not going to Perth
we're going to Sydney if you're in
Australia come see us in Sydney I
apologize but that's just we're not a
rock and roll band we're not on tour we
actually have a bunch of work to do
outside of the muster so we can't do
musters all the time so yeah if you want
to come go to extreme ownership comm
check for the dates for America in 2020
will be coming out soon if you want to
come and check us out go to trim
ownership calm
EF overwatch right now we are taking
trained leadership experts from Special
Operations from combat aviation and we
are placing them into companies that
need leadership inside their
organization the type of leadership that
understands the principles of combat
leadership that we teach inside of our
company Isilon from the things the
principles from extreme extreme
ownership the principles are from the
dichotomy leadership so go to EF
overwatch comm if you need leaders in
your company and if you want to continue
to communicate with us where on the
interwebs we're on Twitter Instagram and
we are on on that old Facebook e for the
Travis Manion foundation they are on the
interwebs at Travis Manion dot org
they're on Twitter at TM foundation
Instagram is Travis Mandan foundation
and Facebook is a hat Travis Manion
foundation and they also have a YouTube
channel which is called Travis Manion
foundation there's a videos there's
digest there's two of me on there I know
I did one but there's two there's a
bunch of other really great stories on
there to hear and to watch and if you
want to talk to well us echo is at Echo
Charles and I am at Jocko Wellington
thanks once again to Ryan Mannion for
everything that she is done and is doing
and to her co-authors and her friends
Amy Looney hefferman and Heather Kelly
for writing this book the knock on the
door which I know is going to help so
many people and of course thank you to
the true heroes that they knew and they
love Travis Manion Brendon Looney Robert
Kelly who willingly went forward into
harm's way and laid down their lives on
the altar of freedom
giving us this precious gift that we
must never take for granted we must live
to make them proud follow their example
and be grateful for their service and
sacrifice just as we must be thankful to
all of our armed services for what they
do every day and the efforts they put
forth to protect our freedoms and to our
police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and EMTs and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and Border Patrol and Secret Service and
all the first responders you also make
sacrifices every day to protect our way
of life so thank you to you all as well
and to everyone else out there just
remember the life is short
and life is precious and it will come to
an end you are not guaranteed tomorrow
so don't wait don't wait to do the
things you want to do and don't wait to
become the person you want to become
don't wait go out there today and get
after it
until next time this is echo and Jocko